let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud
and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
welcome to the midas touch network's
coverage of day eight of the january
sixth select hearing
uh here on the midas touch network thank
you for joining us
make sure to hit the subscribe button
down below
as you join us here on the midas touch
network you do not want to miss the
august hearings this is the season
finale
of the hearings tonight we are going to
hear the tick tock of the
187 minutes i'm your host tony michaels
from the tony michaels podcast we will
be joined by the minus touch network's
panel today just like we have in all the
other hearings i appreciate all the
audience members coming back time and
time again through these hearings it is
a very important
civic duty to watch these hearings and
make sure you know exactly what happened
the january 6th select committee has
done such a good job
of actually delivering us the story
of january 6 not just the day but the
lead up to january 6 rather be the
the white house meeting on december 18th
where donald trump pressured the doj
or rather it be the
the illegal pressuring of
vice president mike pence
as well
and we know the day of january 6
that donald trump with the information
that he was given knew his supporters
were armed and ready to commit violence
and he still encouraged them to go to
the capitol
and tonight we will find out what he did
in the
187 minutes but more importantly
what he did not do in that 187 minutes
to stop the violent mob the armed
violent mob
to go to our capital
in aim of an insurrection and
overturning our vote we the people
who
participated in one of the if not the
most secure election in our country's
history
because of the pandemic in 2020
and the precautions that were taken
because of that pandemic
but we participated in that election and
he
the president of the united states at
the time donald trump tried to
steal the election away
with his violent mob by releasing them
on our government and our capital and
doing nothing for 187 minutes and i
think that is exactly
what the select committee is going to
get to
tonight this is the second prime time
hearing
again this is the season finale as it
were in this series of hearings because
of the evidence that has piled
up since the very first hearing they
they are giving the signal that there
are going to be more hearings in august
so i encourage you
i encourage you to follow the minus
touch network right here on youtube to
make sure you don't miss those hearings
as well
make sure to follow the minus touch
network
for all those hearings that are coming
and also if you're in the chat on
youtube tonight
know that this is independent journalism
at its best
midas touch networks with the myself
brothers have licensed these cameras
that you will see on this production and
the production of all the other hearings
before and after we have licensed those
cameras it is quite the expense
so make sure you're supporting
independent journalism
by giving what you can where you can
rather be your support or something in
the chat there
you will find that in the chat on
youtube so thank you for joining us i
want to get to my first guest
uh susie schuster she's the head of
magnetic media group
but you will also know her as the person
who helped create the ads with rick
wilson from the lincoln project
susie how are you uh this evening
i'm great thank you so much for having
me tonight absolutely absolutely so as
someone who has created the political
ads in this climate and you helped
lincoln project in 2020
what what do you see is the landscape
here as as this series of hearings comes
to a close what's the importance what's
the significance
this is nothing more than the most
important civics lesson that we've seen
in our lifetime
this is a chance for people to see in
real time what exactly happened on
january 6 our job
as ad creators is to take the facts and
boil them down to 30 seconds 60 seconds
a minute 30 so that the american public
can digest what's happening but this is
a chance to actually see it laid out
you've got two military veterans and
elaine luria and adam kinzinger who are
going to be out front asking these
questions to people who have put their
lives on the line for this country and
they watched as a mob
took over our capital i thought was
really important how you said our
capital i think it's also important to
point out from a civic's perspective
that this is a civilian-led military we
are on the brink of a military overtake
which means nothing short of a democracy
turning into
um
turning into a dictatorship when a
military is in control of the military
not a civilian-led military that's when
you see governments collapse and we were
moments from that i think that we are
all very clear on that so
as we point out this lesson in civics
the most important thing you can do is
vote and the second most important thing
that you can do is watch this and absorb
it this is
you might even say this is the closest
thing to the running man remember that
movie from the 70s with richard dawson
when we're actually seeing things happen
in front of your eyes that you can't
believe we're seeing
our democracy working and we're seeing
firsthand how it could have failed in
the most spectacular of ways
so it seems like these select hearings
are also moving the needle because there
are a lot of ads out there since you
took the ads perspective there are a lot
of ads out there that are starting to
hit the airwaves to let people know
because
it seems as if people are changing their
minds
and i was chatting with some folks
beforehand in a in a text thread and i
said i don't actually know what people
are changing their minds i think some
americans didn't even know what happened
on january 6 and i think that's why it
is so important and how do we get that
message out there coming from someone
who has done messaging in ads before how
do we get that messaging out there to
those americans who may be changing
their mind but may not have even had any
clue of what exactly happened on january
6. all right so two things and the first
thing is what you said in the very
beginning independent journalism things
like this things like a podcast like
yours things like the mt network to be
able to come straight to viewers and
talk to you guys as you're watching this
about what we're seeing happening and
not filtered through a network and that
filtered through a whole bunch of
producers or people at the top we're
telling you exactly what's happening and
that is perhaps the most important thing
you could even think about is that these
independent news divisions are telling
you what happened but as somebody whose
job it is to try to convince you to vote
a certain way nothing is more realistic
and frightening and more impactful to
teach you how to vote the right way or
to ask you to vote the right way then
the news i i mean yuvaldi how many
people are changing their minds because
they see more children pulverized more
organs liquefied by ar-15s more people
are asking for sensible gun laws
um
from the january 6 we're seeing
people's reaction to seeing a government
basically
taking over in a way in which that the
president sat by and watched as an angry
mob went after his vice president
we've never seen that before in the
history of our country
and then on top of that as you look at
what we're going to teach you and what
we're asking you to absorb
through these ads there's nothing that's
more stark than the truth
and so i can take this january 6
committee and i can take the next two
hours and boil them down to 30 seconds
and oftentimes in this digital age
that's most impactful sometimes people
just can't handle the enormity of the
hour and a half or two hours so our job
is ad writers are number one to reach
you in your heart to reach you in your
gut and to number two disseminate that
news in a way in which you can absorb it
because this digital age has basically
fried people's ability to comprehend
anything that goes on longer than two to
five minutes i i couldn't agree more
that i think that that is what has
actually changed
some of the perspective from americans
about these hearings we
even some of the trivial things that
seem like well what does that have to do
with it like the ketchup on the wall and
and the secret service in the van but
you start to see
this picture unfold with those little
tidbits that americans will actually
cling on to and go oh yes now i remember
that i remember that here's this little
tidbit here's this little tidbit and
they start to put this picture together
and i think that is most important but
tonight
you brought up vice vice president mike
pence the former vice president there
were there were photos of him what
appeared to be a parking garage or a
loading dock where it appeared that he
was trying to hold the government
together as it were in those moments do
you think before i before i go on to my
next desk do you think that we're going
to hear not just what the president
wasn't doing but maybe on the opposite
side of the spectrum what mike pence was
doing in that moment i think 100 percent
look we all know what president trump
was doing he fell in love with watching
the mob he sat there watching it on tv
people around him implored to do
something even his own wife implored him
to do something and his daughter and he
sat there in love with watching his
followers and it took hours and hours
before he would send out that tweet
saying i love you people who are
desecrating our capital who are
defecating in the hallways who would
have possibly killed nancy pelosi aoc
any of these people mike pence and by
the way let me remind you all watching
that that mob couldn't tell the
difference between a republican senator
and a democratic senator they would have
seen a politician and been enraged and
act upon it and that's the thing that
really really kills me
is that we have 435 representatives and
you're telling me that they could have
said don't don't don't attack me i'm a
republican they should have all been in
fear for their lives and i think that's
what we're going to see play out tonight
i think we all know that mike pence
tried to tell him to call off the mob we
all know that mike pence
was fearful for his own life and we all
know as as well that the vice president
uh elect kamala harris we're talking
about people
across the board were fearful for their
lives
and it didn't matter to him because
donald trump was in love with watching
these terrorists desecrate our capital
that was more important to him
than being president i think that's what
we're going to see tonight thank you
susie for joining us i appreciate uh
your insight into some of those titbits
that americans need to take away from
this and how that story can develop in
the narrative thank you very much for
joining us i appreciate it uh you have a
good one susie my pleasure
uh so i want to bring in a legal
perspective here and you know one of our
uh
favorite
to go to this morning i had a little
snafu on my show i actually accidentally
pressed the pop poppin button um and it
just it it people were confused they
were like oh is there a po poc moment
well if anyone out there who was
watching the show this morning here is
your pop moment i want to welcome
michael popock from legal af michael
popock how are you i'm doing great you
had a advert
pop in it was a little snafu i clicked
the wrong button you know and and you
know there's a lot of things going on
over here at my command center and they
were like whoa are we having a pop pop
in today well here is their pop popping
so pop give us the rundown
not just on the legal aspect but because
you've always done a really good job of
breaking down some of these witnesses
for us we're supposed to see from a
former national security council advisor
to the white house and also the former
deputy white house press secretary sarah
matthews so give us
from a legal perspective what do you
think about tonight's hearings
tony at least you did something you
pushed a button today this this eighth
session of the john six hearings all
about trump not doing a darn thing
nero at least fiddled while rome burned
trump did nothing while the capital
burned in fact he did worse than that
there's a tweet that was the
or the straw that broke the capitals
back that led to
matt pottinger
and sarah matthews resigning almost on
the spot we're going to talk about that
first thing tonight that our followers
and listeners should look for is there's
going to be a whole lot of military
brass on display tonight
we're going to start with lieutenant
colonels
on the air force of adam kinzinger
kinzinger who's actually going to be
hosting tonight along with
former commander
of the navy elaine luria
they're leading tonight's
they're leading tonight's prosecution of
the case against trump we're going to
hear from major
matt pottinger
who was the deputy secretary um
uh the deputy secretary for uh security
the highest level person in the west
wing who resigned on jan 6.
we're going to hear from lieutenant
general
keith kelly
who at the time was pence's national
security adviser
and we're going to hear from
sarah matthews
who was kaylee mcinerney's
second-in-command deputy press secretary
who also resigned on one-sixth for the
same reason that
pattinger resigned because of the tweet
that trump finally got around to sending
at 224 while the capital burned
throwing gasoline on the fire and
attacking mike pence again instead of
doing what he should have done which is
send in the national guard
and also try to quell
the disturbance and send them all home
by taking to the airwaves which of
course we know he didn't do because he
was absent
for 187 minutes which tonight is going
to be framed as a dereliction of duty as
the commander-in-chief and there's no
better people to prosecute that issue
than people who serve this country with
distinction including in wartime in
afghanistan
and i think it's going to be as riveting
if not more so if that's possible than
cassidy hutchinson
sarah matthews
is going to reinforce and corroborate
all of what cassidy hutchinson said and
try to rehabilitate her reputation which
took a hit
by the right-wing media and
right-wingers who said who is cassidy
hutchinson uh uh you know she she was a
nobody that's a lie
and sarah matthews is going to say that
that's a lie that she that cassidy
hutchinson had a very important role
that everybody knew her she was
respected at the white house and you
need to listen to her testimony and
that's what sarah bathy's going to say
she's also going to testify i believe
today about what happened to the dining
room with trump sitting watching
television
instead of doing something to put down
the disturbance that he that he started
we're going to hear from i believe we're
going to hear from former lieutenant
general keith kelly pence's national
security adviser who's going to testify
about
uh ivanka trump don jr
sean hannity and others meadows
imploring the president
to put down the to put down the riot put
down the insurrection do something say
something and he refused all of that
we're going to see a video of outtakes a
blooper reel of trump trying to put
together an appropriate day after
video
denouncing the insurrection
talking about a peaceful transfer of
power and why it took him so many takes
in order to come up with what we finally
saw on television because he never
really wanted to say that he didn't want
to
he did not want to declare
victory for joe biden he did not want to
support a peaceful transfer and he did
not want to
attack in any way the insurrectionist he
finally all of the people
around him made him do it but we're
going to see the outtakes of how he
really wanted to do it and then we're
going to see i think finally pat
sipolone again
talking about along with along with
pottinger why was there such a delay in
launching the national guard why were
they not sent to the capitol until 4 32
in the afternoon when everybody knew
that they should have been sent in
earlier why were they delayed and is it
the president responsible for that
that's a rhetorical question pottinger
military
took an oath of office saw what happened
with his commander-in-chief and decided
to resign on the spot given the delay in
the national guard given he given the
tweet attacking pence at the exact wrong
moment
when the riot was going on at the
capitol
that's tonight
so you bring up a lot of strong points
and i think
when you talk about a legal perspective
because there was a memo that was leaked
earlier in the week um and i think there
was some confusion around that memo from
the department of justice and it had
merrick garland's signature on it
yesterday i believe it was a journalist
asked merrick garland
will you prosecute a former president of
the united states
and merrick garland had to repeat
himself several times that no one no one
person
is above the law so having looking
through that prism of maybe even a
criminal court where donald trump could
face criminal prosecution for what has
happened on january 6 or
some of the witness tampering that has
been alluded to after the fact just in
the last several weeks
how do you view this through that lens
is merrick garland going and i know the
audience is dying to know this answer um
is he going to use some of this evidence
that the select committee has gathered
up as they hand it over to doj to
prosecute indict
donald trump for january 6.
let me answer it simply and then i'll go
back it's a complicated answer
yes america arlen's department of
justice is going to take the evidence
wherever it leads including that which
has been developed at the january 6th
level whatever the january 6 committee
has the department of justice has or
will get ultimately and they're doing
their own parallel investigation about
the role of trump i know a lot of people
who are not inside of the department of
justice me included you included are
wondering what is going on
um
why aren't they moving faster you know
the decision to indict a president of
the united states first time in our
entire history is not one that's taken
lightly and you have to have all of the
evidence starting from the bottom to the
top
developed
in order to bring that kind of
indictment he has time it may not be on
our timetable because we're all
frustrated because we're all anxious
because we're all depressed we want it
to be tomorrow but it will be
if it's going to be if that's what the
evidence suggests
merrick garland and his department of
justice will pull the trigger on it the
memo was
i mean i love rachel maddow but the memo
was not a scoop
that is that that policy
of you can't go after a candidate for
office or somebody at the highest level
in the executive branch until you get
approval from the from the uh attorney
general or if it's a lower level person
from your u.s attorney if you're a line
prosecutor that's been in existence
forever every every
uh attorney general from holder to lynch
the democrats all the way through to now
i don't know why she framed it i don't
know if ratings were low that week she
framed it as oh we just got bombshell
memo it's not a bombshell memo and it
does not indicate
what merrick garland is going to do at
the department of justice or not those
that attack him where were they
attacking him when he was almost on the
supreme court when he prosecuted the the
bombing in oklahoma city i mean he's got
a body of work that says he's deliberate
he's methodical but he prosecutes let
him do his job
right it's not on our timetable we love
these hearings but everybody wanted them
six months ago well i think that's a
good point michael and i'm going to go
to my next guest for the politics of it
all
but i think that's a good point about
where do we try
donald trump and everyone wants him
tried in criminal court but tonight
tonight the january 6 select committee
and the american people are going to
indict
donald j trump in the court of public
opinion
i think you put it exactly right i don't
we you talked earlier with susie about
what is the audience for the what what
is is the weather changing
in the right rooms you know what the
drip drip drip
the death of a thousand paper cuts of
eight hearings and all of these
witnesses is having an impact on donald
trump and peeling away
voters and supporters you were seeing
for the first time
a republican saying in right-wing media
i don't think we want to do another
replay all right donald trump we want at
least have a primary a contested primary
and see with that you that that was
unthinkable a year ago
so this is giving people the fig leaf
that they need
to go and to go and say isn't there an
alternative to trump
i think you're right michael popock from
legal af remember and i think also susie
made a good point when we were talking
about independent journalism independent
journalism is definitely what is going
to get this word out just like the legal
af podcast so go to the minus touch
network follow the youtube channel here
to see
legal af every single wednesday and
saturday with michael polk pock karen
and nippolo and ben mizellis and go
download it too go download that that
thing right
yes yes yeah thank you michael bobock
thank you very much cheers
uh so so i want to bring in someone for
the politics before that i want to
mention
again the independent journalism here
that is happening right before your eyes
we have a great panel here tonight with
the midas touch network i'm going to
bring on leigh mcgowan politics girl
another midas touch network contributor
and she's got a great podcast fantastic
podcast more independent journalism just
like what we're talking about so don't
forget to contribute rather you go and
download those episodes you watch those
episodes
but more than anything
i mean practice these episodes rightly
rightly we have to practice these
episodes how are you really i'm good i'm
good i'm trying to stay out of this beam
of sunlight i feel like a vampire i'm
like you know oh okay yeah there's just
so much sun here um yeah but absolutely
we have to practice it every day i
always say you know democracy is
absolutely a participation sport right
you can't watch it you got to do it and
and you do it every single week with
your show and you're trying to guide
people of of these kitchen table issues
and how to look at them through a
kitchen table perspective not
necessarily this this high brow thing
but more of a kitchen table approach to
it so tell us what you think the kitchen
table approaches to tonight's hearing
because i think that's really going to
be important when you're out there
engaging with your family your friends
about these hearings because they really
have to know this stuff what do you
think is going to be important well
listen i think these entire hearings
that's the key about them right it's
it's giving us the words to talk to our
people a lot of people aren't watching
them or didn't watch them or weren't
going to watch them fox wasn't going to
play them then they did um so i'm
actually really curious as what to
expect from this because
um
like you said from my sense of the
previous hearings is they have done a
masterful job at this you know i think
um
they've really laid it out perfectly and
they really took it step by step
quietly succinctly perfectly so i'm
curious about what you expect from
tonight because i find it interesting
that they're planning to do an entire
hearing on the 187 minutes right because
when i look at it i think okay well
trump sicked his mad crowd on the
capitol he wanted to go and hang out
with them because he was drunk with his
own power um as susie said in love with
himself and his own importance
and he wanted to be there and get off on
the destruction that was happening in
his name but the secret service who we
all now know
probably had something to do with it uh
something was involved uh they knew
better and they took him back to the
white house against his wishes so he
could only end up watching it on tv like
the rest of us right um except what he
was watching thrilled him and what we
were watching horrified us right um but
i think it's so telling that things got
out of hand at the capitol um as it got
more violent as it got bigger they
didn't whisk trump off to some bunker
right because they knew he wasn't in any
danger no one called for backup no one
called for the national guard no one
called for the military i remember
watching it and thinking where is the
military right he didn't take any calls
from the people that were begging for
help from the capitol he didn't take
calls from right-wing media voices
begging him to stop because it was
making them look bad right he didn't
take calls from his own children he
didn't listen to his chief of staff he
just
watched
and i'm
wondering what else there is to say
about that but maybe they just want to
walk us through the opportunities he had
to do something and didn't take um as
popock said a total dereliction of duty
right so i'm curious as to why this
committee felt these hours were worthy
of a prime time hearing and i find that
fascinating i'm looking forward to
seeing what they've uncovered i think
you make a good point like what is it
about that we're going to see tonight
right that we don't we're not like yeah
we went into it and watched it but we've
seen this through the hearings right
like we knew some of this stuff and then
here's the evidence going oh my gosh
it's even more effective now that we see
because some of these stuff is drip drip
drip like you said before through the
media and it's always well we have this
source and we have this source and
here's this anonymous source but no
longer are these anonymous sources no
they're not and that's why i find it
interesting when i read people online
they'll say things like oh well you know
these are these are just show hearings
it's just a horse and pony show and i
think
no these are these are mostly republican
witnesses testifying under oath at a
congressional hearing and i think
i think people have forgotten what good
government looks like and i think that
this committee if we learn anything from
any of this is that this is what it
looks like when government works right
we have spent so many years watching
republicans obstruct everything the
democrats do right all through the obama
years mitch mcconnell said his entire
job to make obama a one-term president
and then that didn't happen so his
entire job was to stop any piece of
legislation the democrats wanted to pass
he called himself the grim reaper
because his desk was where bills came to
die right he didn't let obama have a
supreme court seat um and we saw what
happened because of that so we watched
these supreme we watched these senate
hearings and these congressional
hearings basically over the past 10
years but definitely in the past four
years and they've just devolved into
these useless plays for sound bites on
fox news and republicans no longer go to
these committee hearings looking for
answers or solutions they don't write
legislation to address the needs of the
american people they don't vote for the
bills that are written to address the
needs of the american people their whole
job has become obstruction and they say
government is the problem that it
doesn't work and then they work to make
sure that that statement is true right
so they act like these fools they throw
gotcha questions like what is a woman
define a woman right and all these winks
and nods to the far right but
looking at the one six hearings right
it's been such a departure like here are
republicans democrats working together
to get to the bottom of an issue right
using procedure using the rule of law
nothing is all show body nothing is
dramatic no one's trying to get their
five minutes in right everyone's like
today this person will talk i defer to
you i regard my time you know they're
doing the way government is supposed to
work and look how efficient they're
being right this is what government
could look like there's no matt gates
marching to the doors and complaining
he's not a part of it or like lindsey
graham freaking out or you know senator
kennedy pretending he's from the country
when he really went to oxford there's no
screaming jim jordan in this and
literally the republicans could have had
more of their members there they could
have but they blew it right they could
have just thrown sand in the gears but
they blew it they thought the whole
thing would go away and now we're seeing
what it looks like when government works
and what look what it looks like when
you put the american people and truth
first and it is
something wonderful to watch
i agree with you i think sometimes we
forget the government is supposed to be
boring it's not you know because i say
so many times i mean i don't think it's
boring i think government's supposed to
be stayed it's not there for a show it's
not a freaking reality show they are
they are making our laws
to run our nation it shouldn't be oh i
got this great sick burn and i got it on
tv like that is not what politics is for
well right they're they're they're
trying to
uh play politics for that five minutes
on on fox news and and i i say this so
many times it feels like we are at the
intersection of wrestlemania and real
life right and and it's this
intersection and and politics has become
this entertainment this showboat thing
is exciting yeah but
tonight you bring up a good point benny
thompson has tested positive for covid
and it's going to be a republican who is
going to throw down the gamble i believe
liz cheney is going to who was who was
third in leadership
people forget she is an absolute lifer
republican who her father is who she was
she was number three in the line of
succession in the republican party until
she was removed for not playing ball for
not being
a team player right and but she is a
republican through and through there's
not a single thing that she and i agree
on except democracy matters and
you follow the rule of law and that's
where she is so i'm excited to see her
run this committee i think she's handled
herself beautifully through all of this
and yet again i say that not as a
personal fan but as a fan of her um
i guess love of the country
just just just in in that hint of
pro-democracy we can get along right
where we
if we all agree that it does matter if
the people have a say in a government by
the people for the people then yeah i
can get along i i think you make great
points and everyone go watch
go watch politics girl podcast oh yeah
please we're doing an entire podcast on
this i'm taping it tomorrow on the 1-6
hearings we're going to break it all
down
with david bender it's gonna be just
great uh so that'll drop next tuesday
like listen to that i think people will
love it awesome so subscribe to the
minus touch network right now and go
download that as well on all the
directories apple spotify google your
favorite directory it'll be there thank
you thank you lee for joining us again i
really do appreciate
you joining us here i really do thank
you very much you have you have a great
one and and stick around i'm i'm i want
to bring you back at the end are you
coming back are you coming back i can
come back i gotta go watch it first and
see what's happening in those 187
minutes i want to get your insight as
the next guest would say i want to get
your insight on what you hear
in this hearing uh afterwards so thank
you for for joining us of course tony
thank you thank you i want to bring in
our next guest you know her here on the
midas touch network as the trump nda
killer
jessica denson jessica how are you this
evening are you ready for this hearing i
know you are we talked earlier this week
and you you were excited about this i am
ready i'm ready and i'm so
uh
you know
great lead in we just had from lee
mcgowan from popock um from susie uh
they they all had that theme
of dereliction of duty which is what the
theme of tonight's hearing is going to
be
and as um a couple of them said
don't forget that the ones leading this
hearing tonight are elaine lauria and
adam kinsinger themselves
veterans veterans who understand what
the real meaning of courage and
sacrifice and duty are in sharp
sharp contrast to the man donald trump
who in 70 plus years on this planet has
never lived a day for anybody but
himself
so that contrast is going to be very
very clear tonight
um
as far as what to expect or or why this
hearing um
what could possibly be shown tonight as
lee was talking about i i'm really
really excited to see because i will
never forget that first prime time
hearing and how
visceral and um you know evocative of
our memories of that day it was
and what have they done in the time
between that first prime time hearing
and tonight
they have
told us
the background of the big lie they have
totally debunked the fiction that the
election was ever stolen that there was
ever a legitimate reason for donald
trump to carry forward this attempted
overthrow the fake elector scheme the
pressuring of the georgia secretary of
state all of these efforts to overthrow
the election they have laid the
groundwork
for why they are illegitimate and now
we return we come full circle to that
day
and we're talking a lot about you know
how this how this committee and their
phenomenal flawless presentation has
brought so many
people um into the light but as as um
one of our commentators said previously
not only changing people's minds but
just showing them these facts for the
first time i mean literally for the
first time you have to understand this
is a gaslit nation that we live in and
because of the rhetoric of donald trump
and his his um sycophants and and
supporters in right-wing media there are
many people that went in to the date
january 6 2021 with the notion and
belief that the election had in fact
been stolen that it was rigged in joe
biden's favor for any number of the
conspiracy unfounded conspiracy theories
that they were furthering so
just put yourself in that
distorted um you know box for a moment
and then arrive at january 6 and see
people we all know they were rioters and
terrorists but seeing that from a
perspective of thinking that an election
actually was stolen
is quite different than now what we are
going to see tonight with this
this educated background that the whole
country has been given so
uh exquisitely and excellently by this
january 6th committee that they had no
legitimate reason to be there they were
led there by a treasonous traitor named
donald trump and it's
really i think
this could not be a more significant
moment that we are witnessing
donald trump
as we know
had foreign help to get into the
position that he got into he he makes
his belief his followers believe that
he's a patriot that he's a defender of
freedom a lover of this country it is
the complete opposite of what he
demonstrates and what his history has
been he has been supported and backed by
foreign governments they have bailed him
out of bankruptcy and
saved his businesses
there is incredible
uh evidence that he is a foreign asset
and what did he do on january 6th
he led he was an enemy from within he
led an enemy army believing some of them
that they were acting in
the furtherance of american freedom and
patriotism but they were his gaslit
enemy army this is something we have
never seen and it something that we
absolutely have to handle moving forward
we cannot move forward with any
credibility as the leader of the free
world if we do not take care of the
situation
i think you're spot on about moving
forward and making sure that all the
truth is out there rather it's
even after tonight they they plan on
having more hearings in august um even
so again i stress that independent
journalism because jessica independently
you took down
you took down the trump campaign's nda
by yourself so this independent
journalism thing is so
is so crucial i think that's why so many
people are watching because normal
average people are out here paying
attention wanting to know exactly what's
happening and i appreciate you joining
us and i know i know
you're a favorite here on the mind is
touch network so i want you if you can
to join us during the break if there is
one and join us afterwards but tell us
tell me before you before we go
just 187 minutes of what trump didn't do
because you've been in the room you've
been in the room when there wasn't
things being done so tell us what you
think is going to be the number one
thing to pay attention to
when the committee is trying to get
penis the picture of him doing nothing
about what you just described of him
rotting on our country
you just have to remember that this is a
man that lives for himself and for
himself alone
and the
the
lack of that what is what is the title
one of the titles of the president
commander in chief nobody forced his
hand on that bible to take that oath he
took that oath he violated that oath i
would argue many times before january
6th but in a
in
he betrayed this country and allowed a
terrorist attack on our capital the
citadel of democracy on the most
symbolic
day
in
what we do every election
bring forward the will of the people
certify the votes of the will of the
people and this man has nothing to do
with america he does not care about our
constitution our democracy he was living
for one man and if it meant burning down
the capital and it served his purposes
he was quite satisfied with that well
thank you jessica and please join us if
you can in the break-in afterwards i'd
love to keep you on the panel and and
have your your insight into the hearings
and what we what we get out of the
hearings tonight and the things that we
hear so i appreciate your insight into
everything um thank you jessica we'll
talk to you very soon
i want to bring in my next guest
actually i got two i got two guys here
in the wings and
i can't tell which one is which here i
can't really tell which one is which
cause they both got hats on so i think
i'm just gonna bring them bring them
both in here um we have texas paul
joining us hey texas paul and then i
have so this has been my zealot so we
got texas been here texas paul and texas
has been uh how are you how are you
fellas
doing great tony doing great how are you
i'm i'm doing fantastic i'm very excited
texas paul i'll go to you first and then
and then i'll let i'll let ben give some
shameless plug for the minus touch
network here because i know he's he's
probably wanting to do that here i know
he always wants to give that but
texas paul what do you what do you
expect to hear from tonight about what
what trump did but more importantly what
he didn't do
well this is going to be cassidy
hutchinson plus
um
you know you've got matt pottinger and
and sarah matthews these are two maga
people these were these were not
people that were you know just pros
brought in these are people that were
absolutely devoted to trump uh you know
matt pottinger being the deputy deputy
uh
secretary for uh
um
tongue tie deputy national security
adviser and then you know your deputy
press secretary that worked with kaylee
mecananny
these were not people that were just
outside people that were just you know
anybody they saw enough that day
that they were so sick and
possibly worried for their own legal
futures that they dropped resignations
on the desk i mean they were done
so
we're not just going to see
you know
mango mussolini sitting in the the
dining room
having a good chuckle at what he's
seeing there's going to be a lot more to
this there's going to be
you have to imagine the kind of chaos
that was going on in the background
where these discussions were happening
because these like i said these
resignations didn't happen in a vacuum
you know they didn't just decide on
their own there's going to be we're
going to get these conversations back
and forth i talked to this person i
talked to tornado i talked to this
person
and this is what was happening and this
is why i couldn't take it anymore
this is going to be cassidy hutchinson
on steroids do you agree with that ben
do you think you think that's that's
where the direction of this goes where
we get inside the room where trump was
and and again more importantly probably
what i mean he was sipping on diet coke
and and probably cheering at the tv like
it was a football game almost but maybe
maybe we'll get a sense of that inside
the room do you think more importantly
we're going to get to the bottom of what
he wasn't doing
i think we are 100 187
minutes we're going to see a step by
step of what trump didn't do
during those
187 minutes which has been phrased
appropriately as a dereliction of duty
and you know the term dereliction of
duty
for marines for the navy for our armed
forces
is a crime and he is the
commander-in-chief and though there
could be dispute and debate whether
military law applies for it applies to
him in that setting you know clearly the
doj is going to be looking at our
federal statutes that they can charge
him with but you know we've always heard
the expression right tony texas paul
about how nero played the fiddle as rome
burn in year 64 as the circus maximus
was on fire nero the emperor of rome
literally did nothing but play his
fiddle well the version of that is trump
actually lighting the flame that led to
the insurrection drinking his diet coke
and cheering on the insurrection which
was an attempt to destroy our democracy
in addition to
187 minutes in addition to what texas
paul says about sarah matthews and
matthew pottinger i do want to talk also
about which members of congress are
going to be leading this hearing and
that's adam kinzinger and elaine luria
on both military vets elaine lyria
congresswoman lyria was a nuclear
trained surface warfare officer with two
decades of experience in the navy and so
to have these two vets and that contrast
that will be put on is something i would
definitely look out for as well and then
i'll tell everybody just watching this
as well here's the shameless plug part
of it thank you all for supporting the
independent media free from all of the
corporate bs that's how we have these
incredible panelists people like texas
paul people like tony we license this
footage in a proprietary way we don't
give you the streams that are coming
from other networks like you see out
there thank you to everybody who's
contributed and thank you to everybody
you can contribute on the youtube page
and just thank you for everyone who
supports it who spreads the word make
sure right now in addition to
contributing you can tell all of your
friends family colleagues watch this
right now send this link to everybody
and we so appreciate all of your support
and make sure to subscribe i am so proud
of this midas media network fighting for
pro democracy and making sure we call
fascists out
well i i agree and so let's let's do
this let's bring in someone else who has
a lot to do
with the midas touch network and i got
another person in the wings here who has
a hat on it's like we're gonna have hat
row again uh brett mizellis and and
david bender um how how are you fellas
how are you i'm doing great it's great
to see a panel it's great to see you
david i gotta say i feel a little left
out everybody in the hat yeah
um so uh to ben's point a minute ago
about uh fiddling while rome burned
uh here's the thing
donald trump has no talent
he couldn't play a fiddle
all he can do is watch television he
i think he can use a remote that's it
he's pretty good at that he's pretty
good all we can do and and what we know
today and and this just in i don't know
if you guys haven't saw this as i was
coming into the studio uh the uh
secret service has been advised that
there may be criminal charges brought
against them for these um
uh what was it an upgrade in their uh
cell phones uh it may be a criminal
upgrade yeah
quote unquote upgrade upgrade exactly so
so that's some breaking news and the
other thing i'm really glad uh that ben
mentioned a minute ago is that this is
dereliction of duty tonight that's what
if we were titling this episode that's
what it's called and elaine luria and
adam kinzinger both having served
they've taken the oath
twice they took it uh when they were in
the service they took it for
their jobs today as members of congress
and the contrast couldn't be more stark
donald trump had to hold his hand on a
bible upside down right side up whatever
it was
but he has not honored his oath
and that is what this is going to be
about tonight now something else i saw
only just coming here was that adam
kinzinger has apparently given us a
little teaser what we're going to see
tonight that some of the uh some of the
witnesses
that were watching him watch tv which is
always fun
uh
include kaylee mcinerney include general
kellogg who the one who ivanka spoke to
and they both agreed that mike pence
was doing the right thing
uh
maybe they didn't get the memo either
so we're going to see that tonight but
we're going to see something that i
think is probably going to tie
everything together let's go back to the
beginning
when they set this up and said that
liz cheney said there were seven points
to this seven points this conspiracy
it's now getting even bigger than that
because this is not this is the end of
season one for these hearings
be clear this is not the end of the
hearings there could be some as early as
next week depending on what breaks
maybe in august certainly in september
definitely they will release a report
with more
live
witnesses and or live discussion on the
part of the panel but this this moment
tonight uh gentlemen and
everyone watching and i'm glad you're
watching it here on the midas touch
network i can do it too
uh look let me be clear you're gonna see
something you will never forget where
you were tonight
because this is the night where they
will tie
donald trump
to crime
and there is no
no other answer to that
uh i will i will tell you that
how can i say this right without tipping
it uh
when they call batman there's a light
that goes into the sky
when when these hearings are over
tonight uh look to the sky
uh
and not for batman
this there's there's going to be a
message here and that's that's as much
after so you'll see it if i could add to
that just a little bit you're absolutely
right this isn't this is not this is
season one the white house version they
haven't even touched what was going on
in the campaign we had breaking news
today that uh christina bob over at oan
was
in ingrained in this whole fake electors
scam she was actually sending memos out
to rudy giuliani
jenna ellis with bernie carrick uh boris
epstein doji joe
degenova and victoria thompson and uh
she was in touch with uh um
matt stroya that is mike kelly's
uh he's mike kelly's chief of staff you
remember him because he's the guy that
was bringing the fake electors to pence
and pence wouldn't take them
um we haven't even heard the campaign
side of the crime yet is my point you
know they were all being counseled and
coordinated by a guy by the name of mike
roman
out of the campaign
you know and so far we've just talked
white house
crime
we still have a whole lot more together
well i i want to i want to do this
someone's late someone's he's always
late now i don't know if he'll be able
to run the microphone but i'm going to
go to brett but what i'm going to do is
bring jordy on and mute his microphone
um see the jordi has like a glass of
wine
yes he is yeah i think
he texas paul brings him cookies the
last time and now he brings his drink
but i'm muting him because he's late but
brett
wow
wow we're going to put jordy on a
performance improvement plan okay
officially on a pip
okay go well good job
what does it even work
i muted him so brett tell us tell us why
jordy figures out that i muted him what
you think of tonight's hearing and and
the commentary that you've heard so far
from the midas touch network um what
what do you expect this to be
i think what texas paul said earlier you
know rings true these are deep mega
people who are speaking tonight these
are people who are with donald trump
till like literally the very last day i
mean i believe pottinger was brought
onto the administration via mike flynn
trader mike flynn if you want to know
where these people come from so the fact
that it's these people speaking out i
think is going to mean something and
they're going to corroborate a lot of
the testimony i believe and i think you
i think that corroboration now is
important especially with everybody on
the right trying to pick at any hall
whatsoever you saw that with the cassidy
hutchinson testimony how immediately
after they tried to find little holes
which were all proven false by the way
but what you have to understand is the
right wing and the right wing media all
operate in this disinformation echo
chamber their whole entire goal is to
inject disinformation into the
conversation so i think it's really
great to have actually true
professionals especially tonight ben
said people with military experience
leading the charge here honorable people
leading the charge here on our side and
going back to what lee aka politics girl
had said earlier imagine this circus
this would have been if kevin mccarthy
actually put people on this panel and
think about the people who he wanted to
put on this panel to inject that
disinformation early on i mean jim
jordan imagine jim jordan being on this
panel we should be very thankful for the
way the january 6 committee has
conducted
this investigation we should be very
thankful for the way they presented
these witnesses and we should be paying
attention to the witnesses that they are
bringing and the reason why they are
bringing these witnesses you notice
basically every single witness has been
a republican they try to claim this as
them sort of partisan witch hunt well if
it's a partisan in any way whatsoever
it's partisan leaning towards
republicans right and so i think it's
important to note that and i think it
really is kind of kryptonite to those
arguments um i'm excited to see what we
got tonight i kind of go into every uh
one of these hearings saying you know we
know the guy did it we know the guy is
guilty the guy tried to install himself
as dictator and overthrow our democracy
i don't know what else we could learn
and then by 10 minutes in i'm like holy
[ __ ]
you know
evidence is there right it's there and
there's more and more that comes out
every day and i think it also shows you
you know why these investigations take
so long i mean think about what we've
even just learned in the past few days
past 24 hours even um that if we you
know tried taking this thing to trial
even last week we wouldn't have had that
evidence so i i think
day by day hour by hour minute by minute
we are uncovering the truth of what
happened that day everybody knows that
trump is guilty who is not in that
disinformation chamber so it's on all of
us to continue to spread the word and to
be unapologetically pro-democracy and to
not give that side any air to just speak
the truth to you to your family to your
social media followers to everybody and
keep spreading the word and share this
link around right now so that everybody
watches these hearings tonight one quick
point before the favorite brother well
while he's drinking actually uh
let me let me
speak to what brett just said
uh there is dereliction of duty on
display tonight and you just pointed it
out and we're grateful for it
kevin mccarthy exhibited dereliction of
duty to his party
uh it's political malpractice not to
have taken a deal to when jordan and the
other were rejected to put three on
this all would have been a circus
everyone would have tuned out on night
one because it would have been a clown
car but he took all of his people and
went home because he couldn't get jim
jordan one other on
that is dereliction of duty that has
worked for the country so i wanna i want
to tip my hat to kevin mccarthy thank
you
[Laughter]
i'll never do that again but well
i i i don't i don't like to do the
mccarthy plug but i want to give jordy
that's one plug right there i want to
give jordy a second to plug because
brett mentioned
unapologetically i'm gonna come in hot
right now i was waiting in in the studio
for 15 minutes so one i was not late two
performance i'm under a performance
improvement plan ben yeah i think more
people need to show up doing these hits
with a line in their hands wow
an immediate tone center tonight is
gonna be a big
night for the rule of law i'm stoked man
and i can't be more thankful for
everyone i can't i can't be more
thankful for everybody tuning in right
now getting ready to watch alongside us
man this is independent media at its
finest and we can't do this without
y'all without the midas mighty who day
in and day out help us help make us
better oh we're throwing up pitch it
pitch it pitch it pitch it
i love that yeah go check out
store.midastouch.com right now get 10
off uh all your gear but specifically go
grab this pin unapologetically
pro-democracy all right i just want to
say thank you all so much for rocking
with us seriously from day one to now
the movement just keeps getting bigger
and bigger and we're nowhere without
y'all and you guys motivate us every day
let me ask you ben he's got the title
favorite brother what is that his
official title or is that something
that's just if the screen says it it
must be true it must be i was going to
say it feels a little forced it feels a
little performative but let me you know
talking about
talking about performative tony one of
the things i'm looking forward to today
though are these trump outtakes where
trump couldn't even get himself to you
know they wrote the words for him to try
to condemn the insurrectionist and
apparently we got the outtakes of trump
just refusing to say the words that were
written another thing i'm looking
forward to as well is when this was
brought to the attention of melania
trump she was doing a photo shoot for a
new rug that she had purchased and she
basically told people stop bugging her
she doesn't want to do anything because
she was focused on getting these photos
taken over at the rug but as we see our
panelists for today as we see sarah
matthews and matthew pottinger taking
the stand remember today's hearing about
187
minutes of dereliction of duty of donald
trump not do taking any action when he
inspired this insurrection and uh i
couldn't be more excited for seeing
democracy work tonight for this panel
for all of the support of the midas
mighty thank you so much
spreading the link contributing money
for these feeds whatever it is we
appreciate all of your support to allow
this independent journalism and
reporting to take place
and again these cameras are independent
so they are they are independent of the
other news networks the images that you
see on the screen are midas touch image
it might just touch network images so
make sure from jordy's pay
well
that's what that's what happens when you
when you're the favorite brothers
bender i see i just read it where your
allegiances lie don't worry don't you
don't worry i think you woke up a
sleeping beast and the team jordy's out
there that's all i said
team jordy i'm just a little upset i'm
not there where the wine is ah there you
go funny well if you do want to support
our cameras and this independent media
company you could chip in using the
super chat feature on youtube all that
money helps us to continue these
hearings to make sure that we're able to
keep them going and keep getting our
cameras and all these hearings and that
we're back for i guess i'll call it
season two when uh season two of the
january six hearings inevitably begin so
thank you for everybody genuinely for
all your support well uh it looks like
the witnesses have taken their their
seats but we're still waiting on the the
committee here so i want to bring in
mike i want to say that go ahead my wife
has made jordy cookies but she has never
made
brett or ben oh here we go here we go
what what is this a jordi commercial
here or something i don't know
i don't know why you didn't let me you
know earlier tonight
jordy's mic again
he's done it i might i might i might
mute paul since he's pushing dory's or
heaven no i'm just kidding i want to
bring in gabe sanchez uh my co-host and
executive producer he's been waiting in
the wing the whole time jordy so yeah i
just i've been patiently waiting back
here
you know small hands and all
just you know just waiting just waiting
for time there's an actual replica of
donald trump's hands that you're holding
yeah i had these molded these are
actually uh trump hands uh so i figured
why not if we're gonna go through the
187 minutes i should have them in my
breast pocket here you know a little
applause always thinking ahead that's
what i love yeah
always always with the funny stuff this
game sanchez always with the funny stuff
as we watch the room start to convene
here um i'll make a point tony is that
we're seeing liz cheney come in now but
we're going to see the chairman
uh benny thompson who has kovit he will
be here but he will be here remotely so
uh when they take their seats i think
the first thing we'll see on our screen
will be chairman thompson
uh remotely gaveling this in well i
appreciate everyone joining us uh please
stick around for the the panel and we're
gonna go to the
we're gonna go to the hearing here um so
everyone hang tight
as liz chaney is going to chair
we know
there she gave me will be in order
without objection the committee stands
adjourned
so there you have it
the eighth
public january 6 select hearing
bombshells
the
footage of the outtakes of donald
trump's
videos of him
well let's just be frank
being a whiny little baby
did not disappoint
i'm going to bring in ben my zealous
one of the hosts of legal af
to respond to the second half of the
hearing and the video of the outtakes
that we witnessed tonight
ben what'd you make of the uh the video
there and the second half of the hearing
wow
wow
wow we were promised bombshells and boy
did the january 6 committee deliver and
tony it wasn't just that donald trump
was acting like a baby or said that he
couldn't that the word yesterday
was apparently a very difficult word for
him to say
but it's also donald trump saying
i don't want to say the election's over
as he was basically just told what he
had to read
to put the
country at ease
to get peace in this country that the
election was over
and every time you hear
liz cheney with her closing statements
she burns them down she just burned
the shade that she was throwing
when she mentioned cassidy hutchinson
and sarah matthews saying they had the
courage but there's 56 year old men that
can't even muster up the courage to not
invoke privilege was
absolutely uh amazing yeah that line was
a complete uh might drop moment right
there for me these 50 60 and
seven-year-old men who hide behind
executive privilege and it's so true i
mean what sarah matthews said so
articulately just so directly you know
to have the courage to one leave on
january 6th and just to sit there and
tell the truth you know what she said
wasn't liz cheney repeated this was that
what donald trump had did was
indefensible and it would be her job to
have to try to defend that if asked
about it
you go back and you read that tweet from
january 6 2021 in its context when you
see all the video footage and everything
that was going on with trump saying
um
he goes these are the things and events
that happen so is that 601. these are
the things and events that happen when a
sacred landslide election victory is so
unceremonious and viciously stripped
away from great patriots who have been
unfairly and badly treated
for so long
you know we forget about that tweet but
how sick how disgusting how
authoritarian can you be that after
everything that went down that that is
what you say calling these people
patriots and not distinguishing between
the the terrorists who were there and
anyone else i mean how horrible is that
with the assistant saying mr president
the assistant to him saying mr president
you know that tweet looks like you're
saying that you were involved in it that
you were responsible for it it seems
like you're taking credit for it and in
fact we also hear that he's making the
phone calls to get you know congress to
overturn the election even after all
this was taken place and how cowardly
again we knew this
about kevin mccarthy but how cowardly is
kevin mccarthy right now he was the one
who had the conversation with trump
saying that trump said that he was
responsible and kevin mccarthy just
hides right now and that's
worse than even the 50 67 year olds who
hide behind executive privilege i mean
kevin mccarthy hides behind the traitor
privilege and that's where he belongs
but big mike drop moment but an
important step for democracy and that's
what adam kinzinger said at the very end
of this though is that at the end of the
day we want to be a stronger
nation we want to be a better democracy
and that's what these hearings are all
about and i think they just hit it out
of the park i think so let's i i pulled
the clip of trump's outtakes let's play
that real quick it's just under two
minutes and then i want to get you to
respond again to this to this clip
watching it the second time whenever
you're ready
i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday
and to those who broke the law
you will pay
you do not represent our movement you do
not represent our country
and if you broke the law
you can't say that
i'm not you i already said you will pay
the demonstrators who infiltrated the
capital
have defied the seat of destiny it's
defiled right see i can't see it very
well okay i'll do this i'm going to do
this let's go but this election is now
over
congress has certified the results i
don't want to say the election's over i
just want to say
congress has certified the results
without saying the election's over okay
about congress
now congress yeah right now
don't go to the paragraph before
okay
i would like to begin by addressing the
heinous attack yesterday
yesterday's a hard word for me
good take the word yesterday because it
doesn't work with
the heinous attack
on our country say on our country
want to say that no no my only goal was
to ensure the integrity of the vote
my only goal was to ensure the integrity
of the vote
just a complete
just
just just a baby just a complete baby
tony the emperor has no clothes he never
had no clothes and watching that it is
so scary to believe that that individual
had the nuclear codes that individual is
a traitor that individual is a [ __ ] i
will never refer to him using the word
former president ever this person is a
traitor fascist dangerous and a freaking
idiot is what we see in the clip so if
the josh howley clip from earlier was
the appetizer
oh this was the filet mignon that we've
been waiting for apologies to all the
vegans out there but then vegetarians
but that's what this was and boy oh boy
did the january 6 committee have their
forks and knives out to eat trump apart
right there and now the question really
is the fallout from that moment i mean
how could you in your right i mean
there's no depth there's no bottom
ben ben i don't i don't want to
interrupt you but uh
lofgren is walked in front of the
microphone here so let's see what she
has to say
the evidence that comes in and then how
we
decide to
you know make it cohere what is the plan
overall
you know you're getting way ahead of us
um you know we're there's certainly a
number of significant leads to fill in
details that have come in and we're
going to
pursue those we're going to figure out
this
uh whole mystery with the secret service
test
but
we you know we solved the mystery
tonight i would say i mean
you know sherlock holmes had the story
where
the dog that didn't bark was the key to
solving the case and here was the
president who didn't act
and that was the key to solving this
case it's like a
security guard in a bank who does
nothing to stop a robbery of the bank
and then you learn that he knows all the
robbers and he helped to form them into
a group and he knew they were armed and
he waved them in
and
the whole thing comes together so you
know we had uh the constitutional
indictment and trial of trump in the
senate which ended with a 57 to 43 vote
um
and this is like
i was thinking about it tonight kind of
a moral trial of the president where the
whole country just gets to use their
common sense
and figure out what happened and there
can be no question that donald trump was
at the absolute center
of the conspiracy to overthrow the
election
and to assault our democracy he did that
and whether there will be a legal trial
that's not up to us that's up to the
department of justice and other
prosecutors in the land but
we're going to we're going to complete
we're going to complete our investment
well i appreciated his comments what was
interesting to me about it was that he's
been saying the exact same thing for
months but i think it had a different
resonance for the public
when he said it because the public has
seen
all of the evidence surface in our
hearings so when he says no one is above
the law people are thinking okay
you know the department of justice is
taking it seriously and well they should
we first meet a lot of kevin mccarthy
that was featured in tonight's hearing
do you believe that
what is the committee going to do that
he's defied this subpoena and why is
this testimony necessary
well i mean kevin mccarthy was a key
witness to these events i mean he was
the lead republican in the house where
all of the action was and so
he was desperately trying to get the
president to act and that conversation
was enormously revealing
where
he says these are your people mr
president
and then trump's response was well maybe
they just care more about election theft
than you do in other words trump knew
exactly what was going on with his mob
and he supported them i said you know
that to me was the dramatic importance
of having him in here
in that way
so so what are you going to do
yeah i mean look we have been emphatic
that people comply with our subpoenas
but we're not going to go on wild goose
chases with people because we're keeping
our eyes on the prize in terms of
assembling a body of evidence that will
you know make the
the story real and make it factual for
people how could we ever ask it
on top of that the senate has come to an
agreement or a deal on the electoral
contact i know that you said that this
is insufficient are you uh do you used
to that's still standard what are your
thoughts on well the potential to reform
the electoral contact uh to prevent
something
here's my take on it and you know we'll
have a lot of time to get into this but
my feeling is that reforming the
electoral account act is necessary
but it is not sufficient
i mean if if all our committee did was
to come out and say that the vice
president of the united states doesn't
have the power to unilaterally nullify
electoral college votes which no serious
person ever believed and only donald
trump was arguing then we obviously will
not have done enough to fortify our
institutions so there's a lot more to do
because there has been an onslaught
against democracy not just uh on the
january sixth
uh joint
session of congress but we saw it take
place at the state level we've seen it
with uh attacks on voter rights we've
seen it on
we've seen it in efforts to overthrow
um
the decisions of
election wars and now to impose
political decisions over election boards
so there's a lot going on and we have to
use this as uh a moment to be very
serious about the attacks on democracy
congressman can i ask you something
about the pipe bombs
is that something that the committee is
learning any information about or is
that something that you guys are leading
entirely to law enforcement
because we still don't know who laid
those pipe bombs
um
as far as i understand and this is not
something i've specifically been working
on but as far as i understand those
remain unsolved crimes and so we don't
have any further information about them
but any any evidence or information we
get we will consider to be part of our
investigation too
i i just i'm not aware of any but i know
it's something that is obviously
consistent
you guys showed outtakes of the january
7th video today but we've heard that
there's you know more than an hour long
of outtakes why did you specifically
choose to show just a piece of
um
you know i think that that question best
goes to
ms gloria and mr kinziger who did such a
great job tonight pulling everything
together i you know i would ask them
about how all of those you know
decisions were made because again i mean
i know just from the hearing that i did
last week um it's very difficult i had
about either nine hours of things i
wanted to use and way to get it down to
two hours
what
do you think of that missing the
president is not
willing to say the election is over what
does that say that even after the riot
there was still this unwillingness to
admit it and there was even an
unwillingness to say peaceful over
tweets well um we can go further than
that if
the newspapers today are to be believed
uh the president still wants wisconsin
to say that the election's not over and
is still looking for a way to reopen it
so to this day he does not accept
uh
the outcome of the election and he is
trying to make
that fiction a litmus test for
participation in the republican party he
wants everyone to accept the big lie
i hope that these hearings have
completely
and once and for all demolished the big
lie
um and if not we see that
he's really trying to operate uh a
political party like a religious cult
on the mississippi secret service text
what uh do you infer from these missing
texts do you think that
secret service might have been involved
in trying to cover up what happened here
were they involved in this effort to
overturn the election what is your
i don't i don't know what it means i'm
not committing to any conclusion
uh other than to say
it's a very
unusual
uh and striking sequence of events and
we
have learned strange things and we want
to get to the bottom of it and we will
get to the point
of new information
about
trump's calls to senators during the
capitol riot is the committee going to
try to solicit
testimony from any members of the senate
um
i don't know the answer to that question
and um
you know you're
you know you're raising a difficult
question of
uh about bicameralism and
the relationship between
uh the two chambers within
congress and so it relates to that and
you know obviously we've encouraged
everyone to come forward
uh
but beyond that i just can't say have
there been discussions about the
legality of that or just
requesting voluntary testimony would
that violate anything
yeah that's all i really want to say
about
congressman what comes next is sort of
what do you think that the american
people kind of need to get out of the
september hearings
let me just say that um we have not
announced september hearings yet we've
not announced any new hearings yet um
but we are continuing both on the
investigative path but now also on the
path of legislative recommendations
which is part of our mandate under house
resolution 503 so
um
you know i i can bet you that there will
be
other hearings in the future but we're
not saying when and we're not saying
exactly what the subjects of them are
and
you know we have a lot of work to do
over the month of august
you guys did receive one test
has that been helpful or enlightening in
any way
um
i did i i don't i don't really remember
it um
i i can't say i really remember it and
we have to assume i mean as you can see
from
the abundant texts that were flying
around that day and as all of you know
who were here there was a lot of texting
going on
it just
defies belief to think that there was
just one text that took place uh within
the secret service on that day we will
get to the bottom of it and um
uh i just i can't remember if there was
much evidentiary mileage in that one
text
tell me when we have to go
do you
should the committee move forward and
try to hold them in contempt
well the the speech or debate clause
says that
members of congress
in doing their work
cannot be
held to legal account outside of
congress itself
now there's a question of
you know what people's work is and what
is covered you know within
um
the ambit of the speech or debate clause
but i would say that um if there are
going to be any effective remedies in
the situation like this and
you know let's hope this remains a
once in every
240 years kind of event but
you know
in a situation like this i would hope
that
remedies would be found within the
congress
so as uh jamie raskin um wraps up here
i'm gonna go back to our panel
um
ben mizellis
um
jamie raskin is trying to answer some of
the questions that we had earlier
about the the footage
and they said there was uh almost nine
hours i think of outtakes and that's the
amount that we got so
um there's obviously some other gold
nuggets somewhere out there i think he
said tony that his speech he had about
nine hours oh yes yes yes yes that's
right and they had to get it down to two
that's right that's right exactly and
first off i want to give kudos though
right now to the midas touch camera
person who gets jamie raskin right there
and i want to remind everybody watching
this that midas touch has our own
proprietary cameras in the capitol
building right now and so it's through
contributions like yours on the youtube
where you can make contributions that
allows this independent journalism to
thrive where we support pro-democracy we
do not both sides issues we don't call
the right-wing just conservative or
republicans we call them out as being
radical right extremists and fascists
which is what all of the media should do
and not both sides issues and if you
want more evidence that these people are
fascists just look at what the house
republicans were tweeting during today's
very
solemn event during today's powerful
impactful important event for our
democracy the fascist political party
known as republicans they're tweeting
this like every 30 minutes they're just
tweeting these things
stories are not facts
all hear say
why don't why don't they have a secret
service agent testifying they never show
what president trump was saying the word
peacefully why
these are what this is what the
republicans are saying are you kidding
me these are fascist idiots and i look
in the eyes of anyone who calls themself
an independent
out there
after watching donald trump give that
whatever you want to call that thing on
january 7th if you are still on the
fence somehow
you're going to throw your support be
behind that
screwed up fascist idiot who tried to
destroy this great country meanwhile you
have on a bipartisan basis adam
kinzinger who served abroad overseas for
our great military
as you have representative lurie sitting
there who controlled our navy nuclear
submarines they're asking the questions
as you have our great police officers
who are sitting there and as you have
trump's aides who are basically saying
and they're text messaging each other
yeah this thing about trump supporting
law enforcement total [ __ ] that's
what they're saying about trump total
[ __ ] and quote you know
what that is of course if trump
acknowledged the dead cop he'd be
implicitly faulting the mob and he won't
do that because they're his people
and he would also be close to
acknowledging that what he lit at the
rally got out of control no way he
acknowledges something that could
ultimately be called his fault if you
support that then you support fascism if
you support that then you support being
a nazi if you support that you support
our enemies you support putin you are
anti-american you are unpatriotic you
are disgusted and so that's who you
support those republicans these fashions
and i'm sick and tired of the media
which is why we created the midas touch
network because i'm sick and tired of
them being called conservative and
somehow being liberal is being against
insurrection that's not being liberal
that's being an american that's what
being a patriot is and we are going to
reclaim what being a patriot is and
that's what the january 6 committee is
doing and that's what everyone who
subscribes to the midas touch media
network doing so make sure you all
subscribe to the midas touch media
network hit that subscribe button right
now support pro democracy content we so
appreciate you we appreciate what you're
doing tony and can't wait to bring out
some of our other great patriotic
panelists true patriots i got someone
waiting in the wings that i can't wait
to see
and hear exactly what her take is on
this on this hearing we we heard from
her before lee mcgowan politics girl but
ben do me a favor because um
if you're gonna come back for the panel
make sure you go get jordy to get his
microphone set up and everything can can
you do that for me and make sure he's
not you know a sauce by the time we get
there no thank you for joining us and if
you want to join the panel just just
come back soon come back soon thank you
ben we'll talk to you soon uh so i want
to go to i want to go to lee mcgowan
politics girl i think she she says she's
uh turning into a vampire or something
over there
basically i'm good i'm i'm tired that
was long and great and wonderful and i
have to tell you i was just listening to
ben and i'm totally fired up i
completely agree i have to say listening
to them read
uh trump's last
his you know his stop it go home we love
you speech right just
i i realize how infuriated i am and how
infuriated i've been for years
um
being called
evil and bad and you know that these
people could have taken it from us and
these people stole our election and
these people could take it away and you
know you're special and you're wonderful
but they were evil and bad i mean he
uses those words and i think here's a
man
who knows he's lying he knows he's lying
he knows what he's saying to his people
is a lie he just watched death and
destruction and carnage and all of these
things and he is still
unprepared to do the script that he's
been given that they are literally
begging him to do
he has to go back to say it was a
landslide election and everyone's a liar
except for me and i just think
i have to say i'm i'm
so angry and every single time i see
those videos of
those patriots
attacking our capital i just i feel sick
to my stomach all over again and i
thought that
that they said it really well tonight
that um
adam kenzinger he said
he turned people's patriotism against
their own country
and
he did it in a planned premeditated way
because he knew he'd get his people on
board and he knew that they would do
whatever he asked them to do and even
has his own people were begging him to
stop he wouldn't do it he refused to
defend our nation he refused to defend
the constitution because
he never cared about our nation or the
constitution right it has never been
about anything
other than him the law means nothing to
him morals mean nothing to him people
mean nothing to him so we're shocked the
constitution means nothing to him of
course it doesn't that never meant
anything the day of the inauguration
meant nothing there was no
wow the solemn occasion of putting my
hand in doing the thing and saying this
oath that people keep talking about the
oath means something the country means
something democracy means
something but it never meant anything to
this man it never did and so
it's not surprising that as they said he
didn't fail to act he chose not to act
and exactly what they said at the end of
tonight they said it wasn't an action it
was his final action to get the result
he wanted because it was never about
anything other than him
absolutely well and i think it shows in
the outtakes of the video where even
even ivanka is trying to guide him
through the word yesterday and guide him
through a few phrases because he's
getting so frustrated he can't even
muster up the courage to to
get through the script and do the video
it's almost like
he was such a baby that he that he knew
he'd lost he didn't want to say it on
camera he didn't want to admit it and
now here he is he's standing in front of
a camera it almost felt like he was
going to walk away um and well he might
have i mean the thing is is that
it's it's easy to make fun of his
childish behavior it's easy to make fun
of his idiocy and his inability to say
words and his complete lack of courage
of course but
i mean it was put really well tonight he
hurt us he has hurt the nation
literally every single person in the
white house was like please say
something and these are trump people
these are people that have his back
these are people that were trying to get
him elected again these are his people
and they were like please stop
and we heard tonight
he hurt our national security he helped
feed the perception that emboldens our
enemies that america is in decline that
america is weak he has helped our
enemies
feed a narrative that divides us and
that is still to this day being used
against us right there are still people
out there ready and willing it to go
forward who are still winning their
elections right now for gop primaries
for governor for secretary of state for
mayors on the big lie which is a
complete fallacy right and kenzinger
said it well he said we need to learn
from this we need to grow from this and
we need to come back stronger from this
and we cannot do that without
accountability
so i think that was one of the greatest
moments when adam kinzinger basically
said moments like this don't um make
democracies weaker it's it's what you do
about it is what can make you stronger i
think that was one of the most powerful
moments i'm not always an adam kinzinger
fan for obvious reasons um liz cheney
either but there was another moment when
liz cheney absolutely burns down pat
sipoloni's house um in the moment where
he she basically calls him a coward for
invoking privilege um
pat cipolloni had the absolute ability
to sit there and not invoke privilege
and tell the american people
what
the at the president at the time donald
trump how he felt about
them wanting to kill his vice president
and he wouldn't do it like he struggled
to even like should i should i not and
you could tell he was holding the words
he's holding the thoughts he's holding
the knowledge and he won't give it to
the american people because it it means
i don't know i don't know why i don't
know if it's ego
it's a weasel he's a weasel i mean i
can't watch that and not think of what a
weasel he is what an opportunist you
know to have the truth at your
fingertips like you said on the tip of
your tongue to know exactly what
happened to know exactly what was in the
room and keep looking at your lawyer
like he's going to save you and you you
keep hedging there was a bunch of men in
these these testimonies that just
hedging trying to make sure that they
could still have a job somewhere else
the lobbying group after and as long as
i can just pretend it is exhausting for
goodness sakes just be
a good person just tell the truth
this man is going to burn it all down
anyway you know
tell the truth watching people
try to
put their own best interest in front of
what they know to be true is painful to
watch and i thought what liz cheney said
about giving a shout out to all the
brave women especially the brave young
women and the
like people like the the women who
worked ruby and and shea
who work and were were attacked by the
trump people all these women that step
forward when so many men
um hid behind their privilege was
i think it was great right to give them
a shout out like that because especially
in a country right now that's giving the
middle finger to women you have all
these women saying like i'm brave enough
to stand up for the constitution and the
country and my oath
beyond my future career beyond
my perception within my party
because i know that this is the right
thing to do
and she even invoked women's suffrage
having mentioned in that room in that
very
in that very actual room yeah well tony
that's the thing i mean listen
liz cheney and i like we said before on
two different sides of of every issue
but
women have fought long and hard for the
rights we have in this country we have
fought to be taken seriously we have
fought to have our voices heard we have
fought for our vote and this is all
women all women um
and
we need to respect the fact that
women by nature are under attack and
always have been under attack we've
always fought just like people who have
fought for civil rights have always
fought to be seen
um in this country you know i think
there's this idea that america has
always been this perfect beautiful
democracy and then all of a sudden here
comes donald trump but it hasn't it
hasn't been you know what i totally
understand what adam schiff was saying
in one of the other hearings when he was
saying
how shay and how her mother ruby had
been attacked is not american is not who
we are and i understand what he's saying
he's saying this is not who we want to
be it's not our morals it's not our
values but it is
who we are and we can't pretend that we
don't have an entire history of treating
black women like garbage or we don't
have an entire history of treating black
people who want to vote or have anything
to do with the voting system terribly
that is
part of american history and i think
thinking we had this beautiful perfect
democracy that just got messed up by
this one man that's not true we have
always fought to be part of democracy
there's always been people women uh
black people people of color indigenous
people who have fought to be included in
the american story and donald trump and
his people all of his enablers represent
this idea of who belongs who democracy
belongs to and i think it's wonderful to
have a republican and a woman
like liz cheney out here saying like
shout out to these people these people
who often have their voices completely
marginalized and to thank them for
standing up when people who have never
had their voice marginalized don't have
the courage to even speak
well i i agree with you because i i keep
telling people this that
everyone wants to make liberalism weak
and it's not a bad thing it's not a bad
thing liberal liberalism is tough
liberalism is the tough long slog to
equality and equity in using democracy
you're getting through compromises
because you're right our history is
is peppered with shame right
it's everywhere but but but we we long
as as a progressive liberal democracy
for a better place in the future and
democracy is hard it is tough
authoritarianism is easy you give one
bonehead the ability to have a magic
wand and tell everyone what they're
gonna do but liberalism is the toughest
the toughest type
of government it is the toughest type of
society lee
tell us about your podcast next week
because i know you're going to do a show
we talked about it earlier but tell us
before you go
about your show and it releases on
tuesday so everybody yeah we drop every
tuesday and this tuesday we are talking
about all of the hearings i'm having
david bender on we're going to discuss
all of the hearings what's come out of
it where we think we're going next
what's coming up and i'm really looking
forward to the conversation because he's
just brilliant and he comes up with a
million analogies that i just love to
dig into and i'm just really looking
forward to it i hope people will listen
to it next tuesday because i think it's
going to be a great episode well
subscribe here on the minus touch
network and catch the video version but
also go download
on politics girl podcast on apple
spotify google anywhere you get your
podcast go download it on tuesday you
will get a synopsis with her and david
bender of the of the hearings apparently
so thank you lee for joining us i really
appreciate you coming and and spending
the late night in the prime time hearing
yeah well listen i appreciate what this
committee has done right i think
kissinger said it perfectly when he said
you can't abandon the truth and remain a
free nation and we have to keep that in
mind as we move forward well thank you
lee for joining us i appreciate it have
a good one we'll see you later we'll see
you soon now i want to bring in our
panel we have a few people here waiting
in the wings to uh give us their take on
the hearing i i i have
some great questions i think in mind for
two women on the panel
but i have i have a
bone i want to pick with my co-host
first um i'm not sure exactly what where
in where in the hell he is um
he
can't get his mic there we go where
where am i right now i can't figure out
where you are i relocated
to a more fitting setting okay it would
be where trump gave his attempt at
saying the word uh yesterday i see i see
so so you're in the yesterday room i see
once yesterday yeah yeah but i'm
thinking you know but we got to keep
moving for the tomorrow room right okay
okay i got you i got you i got you well
let's let's welcome in our other guests
uh jessica denson
heidi feldstein soto and texas paul
uh of course we gotta have texas paul
with us as well we gotta have a hat on
the panel here yeah
so our local hat there texas paul
jessica i wanna go to you first because
lee mentioned something and i wanted to
ask you since liz cheney it left her
lips was about cassidy hutchinson and
sarah matthews and the and the courage
that those two young women had and the
shade that she threw on the 50 60 70
year old men who didn't have the courage
to tell the truth when the truth should
have been told
what was your reaction when liz cheney
give us your reaction because i i
believe it's an important part of this
hearing
like ben said it was not a subtle burn
it was it was not subtle at all calling
out the contrast between the courage of
these young women with their entire
lives in front of them
and
all of the all of the weight and and
negative attention that comes from doing
what they did in contrast to
someone like pat chipolone who if you
remember that clip it was really
stunning and awkward to me where he he
that he was describing how everybody
everybody in the white house was
wanting the violence at the capitol to
stop and the committee questioners asked
him but was there anybody who didn't and
there was this back and forth well you
asked about the staff no i just asked
about who's in the white house and and
he said he's like yeah uh uh i can't i i
uh privilege
that that lack of of courage in this
moment in history this this
gravity
um that we are experiencing and
witnessing that he could not even just
admit that simple thing that he knew
that trump was the only person in that
white house who wanted the violence to
continue
but i want to pick up on some really
important threads both ben and lee have
been talking about and that is that
there was so much filth
under the rug
um
prior to trump's both prior to um
his presidency and just in our country
for years that this is this is kind of
like a moral chemicalization that we are
going through
um that is always difficult these these
experiences that
where we confront things that we have
not been willing to face in the past
when they finally bubble up to the
surface they are very trying um they are
very ugly
and they require great work on our part
to overcome them but this is an
exceptional opportunity that we find
ourselves in and i say this
very much from a personal individual
perspective too because i most certainly
have had that moral chemicalization in
my own life realizing the things that i
did not see and i now understand
but we have this as a country
collectively um an opportunity to
realize what we really need to confront
these fascist forces these undemocratic
forces that are at work in our country
and really um i think the the greatest
function that the trump presidency
served was to expose the dishonesty and
bad faith of the republican party just
how anti-patriotic
they are i'm one who followed them for
years believing that they were the party
of freedom the party of patriotism and i
now realize they are completely the
opposite and i have lived how completely
the opposite
of these these values they are they are
the anti-freedom party the anti-free
speech party i mean i lived this i lived
almost the life of a political dissident
during trump's campaign for speaking my
mind and not a single republican ever
spoke out against his his attacks on
free speech and he still gets away to
this day as being hailed as some
champion of free speech in the
republican party as well they are the
enemies of free speech enemies of choice
enemy they are the promoters of
government oppression and suppression
for goodness sakes just look at what's
being done um with women's reproductive
rights and just you know yesterday on
contraception it is could not be clearer
and all of these things now are coming
to the surface in addition
to
handling as we must
the first ever
president in our
country's history who committed treason
and i just i put it on my twitter feed i
retweeted it right before i came on here
the definition that the us code defining
treason
we could not possibly have this law on
the books
and not enforce it when it is violated
as it has been as we saw so vividly
today um and i want to just we we
reference a lot of the a lot of the
former
um the former witnesses in the january 6
hearings and one of my favorite i love
all the women too but one of my favorite
was judge luddig and remember his
eloquent slow speaking but eloquent
speech on the rule of law if we don't
utilize these laws then we have nothing
to hold us up anymore so well i speaking
of the law i want to go to a top
attorney heidi who is running for city
attorney in los angeles she knows a
thing or two about the law i'm sure so
give us your take on the law part of it
and the legal part of it heidi tell tell
me what what is it that we are supposed
to know
about the law
um i'm not sure there was a lot of law
today i mean what i tended to see was a
one-man manure pile of historic
proportions
i saw a man who was an architect
strategist commander and cheerleader
of an
unprecedented effort to undermine our
government and to take government by for
and of the people by force and
appropriate it for himself and so yes
jessica's exactly right that's one of
the definitions of treason it's at a
minimum a definition of sedition if it's
not on behalf of foreign power and
the difficulty i think
is that the criminal courts
have a standard of proof of beyond a
reasonable doubt
and the criminal courts
require a jury of your peers and if you
look at the hurdles
that the department of justice will have
to overcome in a traditional criminal
trial
i understand why the committee is doing
what it's doing and i think that this is
a much bigger service to the american
people because i don't think anybody
watching today
can conclude that this was anybody's
scheme
except donald trump's i mean this was
his con
on his
followers
and so whatever may come of it whether
it's the new york attorney general or
the investigation in georgia or it's you
know a department of justice coming to
account
uh for really a president that has
betrayed
everybody
betrayed his own followers
betrayed his oath as people kept saying
repeatedly
betrayed his base and betrayed everybody
in the country
um i i think that that was laid out
today
in a way that just piece by piece you
could see it falling into place and
there's no other conclusion other than
this man is unfit to hold office this
man is unfit to be respected um and and
what i take away from it is i think that
the political way
in this instance was much better than
the formality and the dryness of a
courtroom with evidentiary objection
burden of proof that's really
much higher
than common sense would otherwise
dictate
i agree with you fully that tonight
donald j trump was
tried convicted and indicted in the
court of public opinion tonight and i
think that is what everyone needs to
understand and i i i always i always
hear this democrats are weak on
messaging and they don't get out there
and they don't say things well on my
show gabe knows this as my co-host i say
politicize
everything and tonight the committee
delivered you an entire mountain a
politicization that you can go to your
neighbors your friends your family
wherever you are to tell them what you
saw tonight on this broadcast and in the
select hearing that you can use to
politicize this and politicizing it
leads me to uh one of the best
politicization machines out there the
guy down there in the hat texas paul
um give us your react your first your
first gut reaction because what i really
want what i want to know from from paul
is his reaction about the outtakes
mainly because i know i know we're going
to get a texas paul video of a reaction
of some of this footage but paul what
did you think
of the of the videotape the outtakes um
not just the hilarity of it but really
to show that this guy was outside his
frame of mind
oh wait you're muted there you're ready
there paul
well it come it just confirms for us
what we've always known is the guy is
actually an idiot he can't read he can't
ride he can barely talk
um you listen to him at his rallies and
he just ambles on there's no real i
don't understand
the draw to this guy for people
that follow him
i mean
i i can't stand to watch his speeches
for more than five minutes he just
annoys the piss out of me and it's not
just because we disagree it's because
he's just a [ __ ]
i mean you you can't
he has no consistent
line of of speech at all he's
just
an idiot and that outtake shows it and
he's a spoiled little child throwing
tantrums and stuff slapping the desk and
you know come on man just make your
statement just do your damn job
what did you take paul from the the
national security standpoint though uh
also as well i'd like to hear your take
on that of what
when they started to talk about how this
has national security implications this
isn't just some fun and games that
happened at the capitol where a bunch of
people in trump costumes went and [ __ ]
on the walls literally they [ __ ] on the
walls um this isn't just that this is
this had national security implications
especially when uh matthew
pottinger the national security council
deputy advisor said hey people from
other countries are calling me and
they're worried what did you make of
that
well you know you had millie calling
china as well i mean it's it was
all about donald trump and that's the
thing is people keep looking at this
wrong trying to understand what's going
on
look at donald trump trump like he's a
criminal
and imagine that he's thinking like a
criminal you know different people that
do different things look at the same
scenario you do and they look at it
differently somebody that works in
security it's always scanning for you
know security weaknesses every somebody
that's a criminal is looking for purses
laying around donald trump
absolutely just cares about donald trump
and yeah he absolutely put us in danger
by weakening our democracy i mean hell
look look what they've done to the
supreme court look at what they've done
to the secret service i mean the secret
service looks as bad as the russian
military right now i mean everything
this man has touched has been fractured
and broken and yeah he left us in a real
pickle there for
in a couple months people were
you had republicans attacking
biden from the from the get-go they had
no idea what we were doing it took
several months to pull our nato allies
back together
donald trump left us in a freaking
mess
in a mess and it and i will always say
this donald trump caused the invasion of
ukraine every life lost in in the
ukraine
is due to donald trump because
putin was operating under the
misconception that this per this damage
that he had done was permanent
he did not think that that joe biden
would have the skill to pull together
the support he did to do the things that
he has done
putin deeply miscalculated
just how
much
there is a difference between a democrat
and a republic
he just
totally did not understand that at all
well jessica i know ukraine is an
important issue to you and you're always
making sure that the audience um does
not forget ukraine and and i know the
national security question is
you know
because that was when i was watching the
tv that day i remember thinking
holy hell what what is the rest of the
world going to see our democracy as now
what damage as far as weakness i mean
what missiles are going to start flying
in because they thought it was over i
mean it looked like as if the president
united states was going to do nothing
and our democracy could be over at any
moment
yeah a couple things there i'll get back
to ukraine for sure um but on the on the
national security um you know crisis
that donald trump basically started on
by allowing this to go on on january 6th
um what took me in the hearing was uh
secretary labor secretary scalia he
talked about calling a cabinet meeting
to steady the ship after um after
january 6th and all i could think of was
why the hell were they not calling a
cabinet meeting to invoke the 25th
amendment
and we remember there was a resolution
that the house passed to invoke the 25th
amendment and it didn't happen and it
damn well should have happened this man
should have been immediately removed how
many how many times have we passed um
egregious behaviors from him and nothing
has been done and the state of our
country and world has suffered for it
so
just a reminder of all these individuals
the cabinet members
who were empowered to invoke the 25th
amendment and did not
but going back to ukraine yes absolutely
this is a
global crisis of impunity for so-called
strong men
flagrant criminals flagrant dictators
the likes of putin and donald trump that
we absolutely must face now um
yesterday was actually the 100-day mark
of imprisonment for a heroic russian
dissident um many of you probably know
him vladimir karamerza
um
not long before he was imprisoned
um he's by the way been twice poisoned
by the kremlin survived poisoning
attempts
and this time returned to russia which
is such a brave
brave thing to do individuals like him
and navalny have said this is our
country if there is going to be a change
made here we have to be the ones
to do it from our own country and you
know we hear a lot of discussion these
days about leaving the united states
telling you if you're a patriot if
you're america an american you can't
leave
it's uh it's ours to fix we're the
living we're the americans it's our job
to do this let us do it let us be the
brave ones the heroic ones that set the
course of history for the future
and stay in our country but going back
to vladimir karam is a 100-day mark
yesterday of his imprisonment of course
unjust
and i
will tell you i am always flattered and
humbled when people retweet me on
twitter but never more so than when
vladimir karamarza retweeted me
and what he retweeted was um a clip that
i put up of him
speaking to jim acosta on cnn about the
frustration that he was experiencing in
the early days of the war on ukraine
just because he has seen the impunity
that putin has enjoyed for decades
the impunity for his actions the
impunity for his terrorism of the
chechnyans of the syrians of his own
people the oppression of his own people
in russia and the effects the obvious
predictable effects of impunity and i
put in that tweet end impunity now
charge trump now and vladimir karim
retweeted me
um
he knows
let us honor the sacrifices and the
bravery and absolute heroism that many
of us have never come even close to to
put your life on the line like that
he knows the consequences of impunity
and we we are it's right here on our
face for us to to handle right now so
let us handle well heidi you put it so
well the architect the strategist the
commander the and the cheer cheerleader
it
he does kind of
this this outtake i i know i know it
seems hilarious but it he does seem like
he wants to be putin like you know as
jessica puts it
this impunity
like that's embodies him that's what he
wants that's what he wants to be he
wants to be a dictator he wants to be
king he wants to be the murderous person
that can say this or that
uh putin kim jong-un all kinds of people
that he got along well with and who on
earth what other president in history
has ever taken his translator's notes or
had a meeting just between himself and
you know the leader of russia or someone
like vladimir putin but i will tell you
i want to leave with a little note of
hope here tony because the fact is a
friend of mine put something i think it
was on linkedin but it stuck with me
because he was talking he's a great
lawyer um has taken a lot of cases to
the supreme court and he's fought a lot
of civil rights issues and he put up
there a quote that was something along
the lines of most people say the glass
is either half empty or half full
i have written about this and i'm now
going to tell us all
whether it's half empty or half full is
not the issue
because the glass is always refillable
so let us dedicate ourselves
to refilling that glass
instead of you know worrying about
how bad it was let's look forward to
what we can do now and i do agree with
jessica that some of what we need to do
now
is hold people to account there have to
be consequences if there are no
consequences the next time it happens
we're not going to be so lucky and we're
going to wind up with a broken glass
instead of a refillable one
i also wanted to take one quick minute
for anyone who was interested on my
comment earlier about the fact that liz
cheney and adam kissinger are
necessary
to the committee's ability to issue
depositions and subpoenas and the reason
for that is if you look at the house
resolution for the 117th congress and
it's specifically house resolution eight
um
and then also the house resolution
forming this committee 503 the chair
doesn't have the power to issue
subpoenas without consultation with the
ranking minority member
so if you didn't have a ranking minority
member you would call in to question the
legality of the entire procedure by
which they've been going and that's one
of the reasons why i at least have been
very grateful
to the two republicans who have stepped
up to be brave that is not to say that
i'm not equally grateful to folks like
raskin okay
and um you know adam schiff and our
heroes because those are my heroes but
i'm also realistic about the fact that
part of the reason why we have a
refillable glass
is that a couple of folks on the other
side of the aisle stood up for what was
truthful and what was right well you
have a great way of putting in heidi i
do appreciate it so tell us tell us
about your your campaign out there and
tell us uh where we can find you tell us
where we can find you i spell my name
funny it's h-y-d-e-e so i apologize for
that but once you see it it's memorable
and my website is hyde the word for for
cityattorney.com
i squeaked by in the primary but as they
say close only counts in horseshoes hand
grenades and dancing
so i am on the
ballot um for november uh if elected i
would be the first woman city attorney
in the history of los angeles and i
really appreciated what um lee said
earlier what jessica said earlier women
we are finding our voices
just as the tides are trying to turn to
silence us and take us back to the
handmaid's tale and so i do feel a bit
of a mission and a bit of a need to
use my voice in podcasts like this and
then hopefully once in office elected to
stand up for women for people of color
for indigenous folks for the lgbtq
community for all of us who have been
marginalized and have been fighting
for our place in society and are now
watching that
at risk
and so my call to action to everyone and
you know my fundraiser would say just
sell yourself i don't i don't i don't
need to do that okay
let's elect
fresh leadership let's go find the woman
the democratic woman running against
kevin mccarthy okay and give her a real
shot
let's look at our landscape and
understand how much there is at stake
in this midterm election and let's not
let it lie
as a low turnout election let's get out
let's vote and let's send a message well
thank you heidi thank you for joining us
today and please please come back
we're going to have more of these
hearings i i'd love to hear more about
that that refillable glass yeah i want
to see season two and a revisit to the
refillable glass so thank you heidi for
joining us thank you very much thank you
for having me tony we'll talk to you
soon we'll talk to you soon uh so gabe
as you um are there in the uh the the
yesterday room
and hopefully tomorrow will come what do
you what do you what do you think this
country's going to take from
the the what we saw tonight
there's going to be part of the country
they didn't watch this and they're going
to wake up tomorrow they're going to go
to work and they're going to hear
the president of the united states
donald trump he tried to overturn the
government and he was a baby
right well i think there's going to be a
few things that we pull out right you're
going to learn that josh hawley was
quick to run away from the problem that
he was there to support right he was
throwing up his fists and saying let's
go insurrectionist but at right when he
his life was at risk he stormed out of
that building faster than you could
actually say josh hawley right you look
at president trump people these are
going to be clippable moments remember
that they are preparing this so that
people remember
these exact moments you've got josh
hawley
you've got trump uh on you know off the
cuff you know people were debating oh
was that speech at 417 in the rose
garden was that off the cuff of course
it was are you telling me that a paid
professional wrote that speech
hell no
no one wrote that thing he was there
just feeding off to say
in a very long-winded answer
do not you know unable to to uh uh to um
admit that there was fault to be put on
these people but again like like it was
mentioned during the hearing if he
admitted that they did wrong then he
would admit guilt
that he was the cause for that
wrongdoing right so then you go to the
yesterday room which i'm in right now he
can't say yesterday these are all
clippable moments where you're going to
say this guy that said he aced the
cognitive test which isn't about acing
the test or anything like that it's
anyway
the fact that he said he aced the
cognitive which is the mocha test right
it's a series of questions he says oh i
got it so good and he's like oh man
camera woman tv right but he can't say
yesterday this guy's supposed to be the
stable genius he's supposed to be the
leader of the free world these are the
people that trumpers just adore
and celebrate
no way
but then you also look at the situation
that they've established which is you
know when they're talking about national
security threat when there is a transfer
of power i don't know if people remember
this but you know after the 2000
election which was a contention as to
who was going to actually be the outcome
winner which was either
bush or gore
it wasn't until six months into bush's
presidency did they have a full security
team or a national security team in
place
and the commission the 911 commission
actually looks at that and identifies
that as a possible threat for why 9 11
happened because we were vulnerable
right and they talked about that tonight
and i think this is just another example
of
of moments when we look weak right and
we're not weak but we have certain
individuals that are trying to
uh make our country look weak right
because they're having a tantrum they
can't say this word they're unwilling to
do this they you know they you know they
were they were what did they say they
were they're all drained after that 417
speech in the rose garden like you're
telling me
that the whole day you're spending in
the dining room watching fox news that
you go give a speech in the rose garden
which you you know give for a few
minutes everyone's like well that's a
take that's that's the best we're going
to get right now you're telling me that
after that whole day that he was drained
and he totally dismisses the efforts of
the capitol police that were there to
protect the people inside which he by
the way is also calling those senators
as they're running for their life and
he's going hey bt dubs make sure to uh
delay the certification like what world
are we living in
you know again a republican is making a
mess and unwilling to look at the [ __ ]
they spread on the walls of the capitol
and say that it was actually their fault
they walk away they run away and say
someone else will deal with it not me
and that is trump and then as a
republican party and i you know to to
say uh to you know what heidi said and
jessica said like
i am very grateful for people like
kenzinger and and uh and and uh cheney
who are willing
to stand up and actually say something
right we we may sit on the complete
opposite end of the spectrum for all the
policies that they have
but this one which is actually how to
protect our government and our democracy
of the united states
i'm very grateful to have them in our
corner right now
well i want to go to um the texas paul
and jessica for one last word texas paul
what what give us your one last take
here and then i'll go to jessica what do
you have for us
for your one thing to remember for
tomorrow in the tomorrow room
yesterday's room but tomorrow's room
tomorrow
well let's answer the question we came
here to answer tonight what did trump do
for 187 minutes the answer is he was
crying that's what he was doing
he uh wanted to go down to the capitol
he wanted to to stop the certification
he did nothing for 187 minutes because
he was trying to see which way it would
come out look at it through a criminal's
eyes and everything you saw today makes
complete sense
i don't want to say that the election is
resolved you know people try to look at
that through their own eyes oh that must
be pride no it's not pride it's it's a
criminal he is still to this day looking
at this through the eyes of a criminal
he is still trying to figure out a way
to beat the rap on this to
to to to
con people to everything
about him is always criminal and if you
look at if you want to know what trump's
going to do in any situation say what
would a criminal do
and that's what you get
that's that that's exactly what you get
the other thing that i'd sum up with is
that liz cheney answered it the second
sentence she came in
yeah we're getting more hearings in
september there will be a season two so
hold on folks we're getting more mm-hmm
oh you're muting yourself yes yeah
all this time and i finally i finally
messed up my mute but i i am very
excited for season two as well i think
it's going to be you know i i we i've
talked about this on our daily show but
like you know season one of the hearings
is very much a world building you're
setting up what happened during and
around january 6th and i think season
two is very much going to be the
character development and us identifying
specific republican lawmakers who helped
trump
especially those who are running for the
2022 midterms right i mean you've got
september october november you've got
all that time to add content to call out
these fascists and these traitors who
are trying to help trump stay in office
and i think that's what we're really
going to see
in season two because we've you know as
we come to the finale we've let we've
led up to january 6th but now there's a
bun there's hours hours of footage we
only just saw don jr we just saw stephen
miller last hearing
there is tons of footage of there of
this hearing that we have not seen yet
from the depositions that i think will
be very revealing in season two
well jessica speaking of depositions in
the trump world and dealing with trump
rules and depositions i know you've done
this time and time again so give us your
final thoughts here uh because another
character that worked its way in was the
guy that kind of helped you bring up in
the 2016 campaign was steve bannon when
he gives this
this
this recording of
where he knew he knew what the strategy
was and it was to steal the election it
doesn't matter what it takes donald
trump's gonna do it so give us your
final take here on the hearings yeah
major takeaway for that like i i've said
before um is that the intent was obvious
to everyone in trump world they knew
that he planned from jump to
stay in power by any means necessary um
i started off today talking about how
today's hearings were going to
paint trump as an enemy from within
and if you heard er
representative elaine lauria who by the
way is in a competitive house race um so
thinking of how we can have a part um as
heidi was saying to to make sure this
moment in history does not pass us hold
the house um hold the senate for
democrats um elaine lauria could use our
help but she wrapped up her say uh her
comments today describing
being a naval officer on ships and and
looking out for enemy ships and she said
i never imagined that the enemy would
come from within
that's what we have that's what we're
dealing with an enemy from within who to
this day
is treated as a legitimate public a
legitimate political figure in american
politics which is just ludicrous
um i want to point out on the women
theme one other extraordinary woman a
woman who i am a huge fan of
who has um you've seen her face in these
hearings you haven't heard her name
but that woman is sandra garza and she
is the partner of the late officer brian
sicknick um there was again a reference
to brian sicknick today
in um bringing up the just the the
disgusting uh fact that trump never even
his his so-called care for the the men
in blue in law and order he never even
acknowledged brian signick's death and
the camera went over to
sandra garza sitting between
officer gannell
and the other among the other capitol
police officers
this woman is extraordinary if you've
ever heard her speak on her media hits
she speaks with such clarity
about the event events of january 6 um
she has you know put her pain to purpose
in in in speaking out about the need for
accountability and a very interesting
fact about her as was true for officer
sicknick is that she used to be a trump
supporter as well and um she could not
be more clear now on the threat that he
poses and and his need for
accountability and i have so much
respect for that woman
so jessica tell us where everyone can
find you um give us your shameless plug
here at the end oh
well as always i'm on twitter
at
jessicadenson07 seven
i do have a lot in the works but
if you want to help me i don't i haven't
done this in a long time but
speaking of depositions we have some
very high profile depositions going on
in my initial lawsuit against the trump
campaign
um
we are hunting down steve bannon if
you've watched this panel before you
know that we are we are on steve
bannon's um
well to get him seated in a deposition
um and this is the lawsuit by the way
that through all of my ins and outs of
the legal system through the past five
years has led me to invalidate the trump
campaign's non-disclosure agreement
without my initial lawsuit which i filed
in 2017 without a lawyer for
discrimination and defamation we would
never have arrived at this point
but that existing lawsuit is ongoing to
this day we are doing high profile
depositions all the time yesterday
um tony knows this
i had a uh
somewhat um
disturbed morning
through a deposition of none other than
kellyanne conway
and yes these depositions and the
process servers um they're very
expensive
i have on my initial case just two
lawyers that are working contingency i
would love to be able to pay them
something for
for all of the dedication that they have
put into um defending democracy in my
case and and broadly so if you want to
support if you want to support that
effort in the legal
the legal fund um
it's pinned to my twitter my twitter
profile it's donorbox.org
slash jessica v trump
and
like i said any help would be would be
greatly appreciated well go go check go
check jessica's uh link out there texas
do you have texas paul do you have one
last shameless plug
uh yeah just a quick 20 second thing i
want to throw out there real quick is 20
seconds 20 seconds
just nailed it though um when she talked
about the argument that was going on in
the press room with the staff
she said
their point of view was
don't say a thing about the violence
because it gives the media a win
that's the way these people think yep
that's it they're not there to govern
they're not there to anything they're
there to burn it all down they're
freaking criminals their democrats and
republicans are not the same
i think she even said she pointed at the
tv and said does it look like we're
[ __ ] winning i think it's what she
said i think is what she said and here
at the midas touch network we are
winning because we're getting more and
more people watching because of these
great panels that we have with the midas
mighty favorite texas paul and the trump
nda killer jessica denson so subscribe
to the midas touch network thank you
texas paul thank you jessica for joining
us come back to these these hearings
that we will have soon thank you very
much my friends
uh gabe i've got a special guest here in
the wings a last-minute guest a
last-minute edition last minute edition
if adam barcaminko is ready adam how are
you i'm good how are you guys oh thank
you and you're doing great doing great
i'm glad you could join us because i
really i want to get a sense from
adam you're a great political strategist
so what does this because i always talk
about this on our show i say politicize
politicize politicize politicize because
they're always like oh don't politicize
things no that's exactly what we need to
do because i believe there's two things
there is government which is policy and
there is politics which is elections and
if you don't do the politics and the
elections you do not get to do the
policy you do not get to govern so tell
us
tell us what tonight hearing
is
what the impact is in the politics of
donald trump well first thank you guys
for having me um last minute of course
uh
i'm so excited to see democrats finally
playing like republicans we gotta we
gotta fight fire with fire we need to
politicize the hell out of this because
at the end of the day
it is political i mean post-trump every
trumpism is here to state nothing's
going away and we see democrats with
large platforms every single day all
they do is attack liz cheney look i
don't care at this point what liz
cheney's politics are what i care about
is she's doing the right thing um she's
on the right side of history for this
country on this and it it for me you
know i think this is a committee that at
this point not to to knock the oversight
committee but this is a committee that
should be here to stay whether it's
through january and beyond i want to see
another hearing in august i want to see
four hearings in august i'm glad to see
chuck schumer finally on video
again we have a lot of questions about
chuck schumer out there as democrats we
should
on video asking how long is it going to
take to get back to work is it going to
be four hours is going to be five hours
we shouldn't be in recess we should be
working round the clock right now we
know we're gonna have a majority in the
house in the senate either next year we
should do everything that we need to do
between now and when the next congress
takes place to keep going
michael phone being harassed outside of
the capitol right now i'm looking at
this one you have pro january 6 people
outside their insurrectionists maybe
it's a good opportunity for the fbi to
take the video tonight and identify the
individuals who we're still trying to
identify from january 6. the outtakes
they were incredible um i think they're
more than we asked for we're finally
putting on a show trump put on a show
with a bunch of [ __ ] we're out there
actually putting on a show with facts
the people that have put that have put
their time and energy into making each
one of these hearings what they are the
outtakes alone should be enough to put
donald trump in handcuffs he isn't and
then i think the final thing is cassidy
hutchinson was right we are you know
this may be popular unpopular but
it's time to bring the marines in i
think you need to disband the secret
service and you need to build from
scratch from top down secret service is
totally corrupt cassidy hutchinson has
been proved correct every single time
and tonight of the three individuals in
the secret service who got private
counsel one of them is not only the
former deputy chief of staff under
donald trump who is currently the deputy
director of the seek service an
individual should have never had that
position
well
i tell you i follow i go on true social
i have an account on true social so that
other people don't have to and i was
just checking it as you were talking as
i was listening there he's going he's
going at it the former guy is losing his
[ __ ] mind i mean absolutely losing it
he didn't tweet or to post truth
whatever the hell it's called over there
he didn't do any of that during the
hearing but but once that outtake came
in because to me this whole time
he was he could be pissed about anything
but i think the secret service story the
ketchup story and these outtakes are
gonna be the thing that absolutely get
in his crawl
the most and i think the committee knew
that and i think they understood
that what gabe was getting at earlier
what you were getting at is this little
clippable thing these little bitty
things that really get not just in his
crawl but in his entire supports crawl
that this idea that somehow you know
gabe's in the yesterday room here
because he couldn't he couldn't say the
word yesterday so tomorrow tomorrow as
democrats as pro-democracy people
emerging to the world tomorrow a
different day than what was today now
everyone knows
what a treasonous piece of [ __ ] this guy
was and what he didn't do for his
democracy and for his oath and his duty
to the law
what do people arm themselves and what
do they say to their community members
their friends their family what do you
think they say going forward to make
sure to politicize this to make sure
that not just donald trump but trumpism
in this country cannot take power and we
don't need this fascism we need to
get these rights for people back that
we've lost over the last few months what
do these people use and what do they say
to politicize this i mean i think
there's probably two things the first is
you need to run
as quickly as you can to the polls or to
vote early as josh hawley ran from the
people
wait wait wait wait he was he was
hauling ass i think someone i think
someone tweeted that he was hauling ass
it was it was pete's husband actually
what what was it yeah i was chasing at
that point of that he was hollering
and he was hauling ass in slow motion i
mean
and i think the second thing is i mean
when you look at the make of the
committee some of which you guys just
talked about is you know people like
elaine lauria who are you know they are
in tough districts i think we should
reach out to these matters and say we
want more of this i mean if if this is
what congress there's so much corruption
if anyone is is is quote unquote you
know draining the swamp it's the january
6 committee and i think whether it was
an unintended consequence or a
self-inflicted wound or
kevin mccarthy had something in him that
made him do the right thing we actually
have this committee because he didn't
put on a bunch of [ __ ] like jim
jordan um so this is actually you know
the counter to conventional wisdom this
is one of the first times we actually
have a committee of people who are
interested in getting the bottom of the
truth and not a bunch of jokers who are
just bullshitting and using the time and
and and playing games so um
you know everyone's got to vote but i
think at the end of the day what we're
watching is incredible they have plenty
of time left they need to just keep
doing this
and uh and i love prime time i'm not i'm
not criticizing them for when they do
them at other hours but i think this was
an incredible night and you know we
whether you believe polls or not there's
been a lot of polling that suggests that
there's independence early on prior to
this committee that didn't believe that
donald trump any involvement i mean it
couldn't be further from the truth if
anyone's paying attention at this point
right well i think well the humans are
definitely i was going to say that the
hearings are definitely doing the
intended purpose of moving the needle
right you had people who either won
didn't know what happened on january 6
and were kind of out of the loop or you
had people who lived in denial right but
having his hearings and exposing all of
these key players for the cowards and
the fascists and the traitors and the
liars that they are
have been very effective to get people
to say
ah
i actually
don't think that he should trump run
again or i you know i don't think that
what he did was good i mean the downside
is there are some people who are saying
oh trump shouldn't run and we should go
for desantis you know for for 2024 which
isn't the great the greatest outcome but
i think the first step and breaking
through that well i i forget who who's
uh it was liz cheney talked about you
know the cracks through the dam right
and this these are the cracks that are
beginning to break apart this dam to let
the floodgates you know come through
which is to expose this party for what
it is and you know hopefully try to
rebuild it
for something better right yeah i mean
the the hypocrisy at every single level
whether whether they get it or not at
some point here you're going to have a
55 of white women who voted for donald
trump who are getting stopped at
mcconnell checkpoints wondering
are they going to wonder they you know
but we have those checkpoints because of
them um you've got donald trump who is
telling people privately in florida that
he doesn't want desantis to lose but he
doesn't want him to win by a lot just by
a little because you know tax evasion he
moved to florida and he is a resident of
florida and he wants to make sure
there's a republican governor um so you
know there's corruption every level but
i think that this committee has been
incredible and i think that between now
and the end they've just got to keep
this up you've got republicans out there
who want to you know one deny that a 10
year old was raped two once the truth
comes out and says oh okay she was raped
however she still has to have that baby
and then they go and they're focused on
the doctor as opposed to the rapist um
it's it's just unbelievable the
walgreens story today about denying you
know condoms i i think this is stuff we
should talk about wait wait wait wait
wait wait i i i've been i've been
focusing on the hearing what the hell
are you talking about walgreens doesn't
have condoms anymore well so the news of
the day is the three of us and others
are no longer shopping at walgreens
walgreens had a staff member who denied
condoms to uh some individuals that came
in customers
on religious beliefs and walgreens is
siding with their staff um and you know
this is just one more thing so this is
like this is like the cake thing all
over again exactly pretty much
wait wait wait
so so a dude walks into why i want to
make sure i track this down the dude
the dude walks into walgreens he goes to
buy condoms and the clerk won't sell him
condoms because he doesn't agree with
the condoms or he doesn't i'm not even
sure if it's a guy it could be a girl i
mean at the end of the day i think
people are either proud or embarrassed
to go and buy condoms whatever it was
they were denied getting those and
walgreens
sided well here's here's the thing adam
is
when when the first leak of the supreme
court decision to overturn roe v wade i
on my show predicted and i my audience
knows this this thing i say doubt me
because it seems as if i have a crystal
ball and it really isn't that
complicated to know where these people
go and what they think you just like
like kind of like texas paul said you
got to think just think of them as
criminals and think like a criminal and
boy you'll get there if you just think
like a fascist boy you'll get to where
they want to be pretty damn quick right
and i said there is going to be a moment
in this country where a trumped up white
dude in a rural state or a blue state is
going to walk into a gas station
somewhere to buy condoms and the clerk
is going to say condoms we don't have
condoms condoms are outlawed and they're
going to say what the hell what do you
mean condoms are out love well didn't
you hear they overturned roe v wade and
they're banning contraception like who's
banning it republicans like wait a
second i vote for republicans and and we
are at those moments we are at those
places that they had they just take [ __ ]
way too
far and it it actually played out
tonight in the select hearing where
trump took this idea that his
supporters his crowd the oath keepers
the proud boys were gonna come to
washington and they were gonna save him
from not being president of the united
states and that's not how it turned out
but now we're seeing the aftermath of it
and i i think if everyone in this
country can just hear the voices out
there and i i appreciate you coming on
the show because i know
you were one of the early ones and the
midas touch movement uh to to believe in
the mizella's brothers and we're
building this network here of of folks
so subscribe to the midas touch network
if you're still still still here with us
late tonight uh for don't forget to
subscribe and again this independent
journalism this across the table talk as
we were talking earlier i think is very
effective
in the realm of media because people are
so tired of getting talked to
um they they want to have a conversation
i think that's what this network is
about and and i know you've been with uh
midas touch and the mizellis brothers
from the from the beginning back in 2020
i believe if i don't have that wrong you
can you can correct me you got it right
well and and so so um tell us what you
think about that what tell us how you
think that independent media is so
important and people to
take independent media seriously and
really look at it and give it a hard
look not seeing that we're trying to
build something here that people can
come to and hear a pro-democracy message
from front to back as opposed to the
bull side's crap or well let's hear from
this person who's a fascist who's
obviously just going to lie to us or
just straight up be right wing tell us
why that's so important yeah i mean it's
incredibly important especially because
this country is still
an experiment that is uh you know
hanging in the balance but i think what
you know ben brett and jordy have done
and all of you that have been part of
this midas network is incredibly
important for a number of reasons one
you can always tell
i i'm right outside of dc but you can
always tell when you're doing something
right when washington dc and new york
and la and others start attacking you
and there was a hit piece in rolling
stone and a number of other individuals
that attacked midas and the midas
network because they're doing really
great work and any time that you shake
up something people get upset there are
a number of stories that never even came
out because the facts were just [ __ ]
it was a bunch of [ __ ] that was that
was uh pitched against them um because
they're working really hard and one of
the things that i respect more than
anything else is the first thing that
they did when they started prior to the
media network is they launched the pack
and with the super pac you share
everything
every expenditure and every contribution
over 200
so not only were they transparent but
they were getting attacked because they
were transparent and shared what they
were doing and they moved past that they
didn't let that you know put them aside
i think they released over 500 video you
know 504 videos made to be exact in
2020. they got millions and millions
millions more video views than you know
uh many of these packs have been around
for you know years that waste 10 20 30
100 million dollars and and yet a number
of old school reporters who just don't
like things to be you know switched up
that we're saying oh you only got this
many points on tv well that's actually
not the truth they they were really
smart and creative and they got millions
and millions of views and they got tons
of earned media that's worth millions of
dollars by only doing a ten thousand
dollar spend from there they expanded
and they look for talent all over the
country they are building with you all
and many others exactly what the left
has needed for years and years and we've
never had and it continues to expand
each week i mean texas paul is a great
example but like
i mean i i talk to the brothers every
single day and there's not a week that
goes by that i don't see that you know
there's someone new that's part of this
network who's getting out there and and
you all are building off of each other
and able to help expand the platform and
the voice that you guys have so i'm i'm
proud to be part of it i consider myself
a step brother
but i love the work that you guys are
doing yeah well uh we appreciate it too
and uh we won't we won't we won't tell
anybody that you're a stepbrother
no problem we promise um it's a great
movie though well it that is that is a
good movie that is a good one gabe did
you have any questions for adam i didn't
mean to monopolize no no not at all i
think i think adam you know he came in
you know it was a it was a nice addition
to the past slide right there at the end
right yeah boom but i think i think
everything that adam has said so far you
know talking about how democrats are
finally doing what they need to do right
they need to step up to the plate and
call this [ __ ] out for what it is right
and they need to you know take a page
out of the republicans playbook you know
not so maybe aggressively in some ways
but they need to do what you know i know
that many people say the democrats need
to be the moral high ground well
times have changed and we do need to
confront what is in front of us and uh
we can't play nice ball all the time and
i think that is exactly what needs to be
happening right here which is to call
everything out and address it and not
back down right yeah and continue to
remind everybody the republican party is
literally the party that is taking the
american flag and beating police
officers with it right that's what it
comes down to every single thing they
pretended to stand for they don't and
it's right it shouldn't happen stripping
stripping rights you know rights that
people have had for for decades and
saying actually
the thing that you thought you had
actually don't have anymore yeah i think
i think there's going to be a whole lot
of people that want you know the
republican party allegedly has been the
one that has wanted people to stay out
of there in government instead of their
bedrooms forever democrats are literally
the ones staying out of people's
bedrooms right and it's on full display
so republicans are the ones that are
like hey are you a boy you girl like
what are you they're the ones who are
trying to in some sick twisted way
trying to find out someone's gender
they're trying to take away books
because it has uh and it says
republicans are the ones that claim
democrats are groomers but republicans
are the ones that want inspiration
and whenever it's brought up you know
whenever there's some staffer that gets
revealed and you're like hey what about
this person that was on your team just
nothing no acknowledgement obviously and
then the very next day it's a call out
it's all projection right and i actually
think the media there's a whole bunch of
people the media should be quoting and
reaching out to for interview on some of
these things like the marriage act they
should reach out to denny hastert they
should reach out to mark foley there's
tons of republicans that are no longer
in congress you know that have shown who
they are that should go on record how
they vote if they were in congress right
right i think you're right i think
you're right and the other thing i want
to i want to close with here besides
again subscribe to the midas touch
network here do us that favor and you do
yourself a favor because these hearings
are going to keep coming but adam
appointed to all the personalities and
all the videos and all the updates
especially ones from jordy myself the
younger brother the favorite brother as
he as he so self
labeled himself earlier um but here's
what i want to say i want to tell the
audience why we still have them here
before we leave is that
this idea and i've been saying this for
weeks that this idea that liberalism is
weak and we we
this hearing proves
that liberalism isn't weak liberalism
stood against a mob liberalism stood
against a person who wanted to overthrow
our democracy
liberalism stood against all those
things and it still survives today
because liberalism is tough because
democracy is tough equality and equity
is not achieved
just lightly it it is a it is a hard
working piece of history that it takes
just like lee mcgowan pointed out
earlier yes there's our our history is
littered with vile things to get us to
where we are today and we must move
forward and we cannot we cannot
let these fascists that are at our front
door take over our institutions and our
government and our democracy because the
thing that they want the most is to take
it away from us because democracy does
not serve them well democracy does not
give them the ability to push their
fascist ideas equity inequality is the
exact opposite thing that they want to
achieve that is pure blooded fascism
and we need to stand against them we
need to be tough because liberalism is
tough and i i get sick of that that
liberalism is weak it is really weak and
really tired and really
it's just pathetic to point to one
person and go i want that one person to
tell me what the hell i'm going to do
what the hell i'm not going to do and
let them decide for the rest of the
people what the hell they're going to do
and what the hell they're that's easy
that's easy the hard thing is democracy
the hard thing is the fight the hard
thing is to use your ballot and engage
with your ballot and i'm just not
talking about marking your ballot i'm
talking about engaging in democracy
rather that be using your talents to
yell and scream into microphones like
some of us here on the midas touch
network do some some people are good at
texting some people are good at writing
you can write postcards hell some people
have some extra cash to give to in these
races where it can and will matter to
save your democracy so do what you can
engage where you can rather it be on a
microphone here on the midas touch
network or in your grocery store at your
clerk asking them did you see the
hearing last night can you believe that
that's a good way to start the
conversation and i think that everyone
needs to remember that democracy
and liberal democracy is not weak
our republic is strong and liberalism is
what makes it strong and we need to stop
walking away from this idea and we need
to embrace the idea that free freedom
and liberty are the strength of our
country and that we can use that to go
forward and we can fight for that rather
it again whether it be with the ballot
with your microphone just having those
conversations with your friends your
family are working for campaigns
whatever it may be that your talent is
and your time is that you can engage in
your democracy because i think that is
the thing that may put america back on
track is once they
really engage in the democracy i think
we'll get there adam give us your final
word
i think that's it
gonna sometimes summed up better well i
i i didn't mean to uh to take the words
out of the mouth i just get i guess get
very passionate here and also if you if
you like if you like those passionate
speeches go follow us me and gabe on
youtube the tony michaels podcast we got
our own channel we broadcast every
single weekday monday through friday
noon eastern 11 central ninth pacific on
youtube twitter twitch and we also
simulcast from the midas touch facebook
page so go follow us over there now
follow adam parkamenko on twitter adam
is there anything else you want to
shamelessly plug at this point
i think that's it but i did all you got
to do everything i'm glad you guys are
this network well i appreciate it thank
you very much we'll talk to you soon my
friend
gabe what a night what a night wow we
are five hours and 20 minutes into this
straight line you know what let's just
let's just pull an all-nighter what are
we just gonna do like eight hours just
like they're still like there's like
five or six thousand of the midas mighty
the loyal midas mighty that are that are
still that are still watching yeah i
could i could pop up another bag of
popcorn you know i could make it okay
well you know we could just we could
just replay the hearing and we can just
watch through it again right
we could put it in like you know super
fast mode we can re-watch it now people
are really leaving like ah this guy
these [ __ ] guys these [ __ ] guys i
actually i i do think that that video
the outtake is gonna get in his crawl
it's gonna get i i already i already can
feel the trolls
in the twitter threads being so pissed
off about that at outtake and people
making fun
of him
not being able to say the words that
people totally deconstructs and breaks
down this idea that trump is this mega
king oh i'm this man who could you know
like it's he is not he is weak right he
is vulnerable he is someone who does not
do well again on with pressure right
he's always going to
put up his arms and he's going to say he
doesn't want to help out when you know
you look at all the meetings of the g20
some you look at different things like
he is not someone who likes to play ball
he only likes to help himself he is a
narcissist he only cares about his ego
he will not do anything
unless it serves himself right you look
at the the fact when they brought up he
went through to get up his things or get
his things out of the dining room and
he's like i'm very disappointed in mike
pence right now you know he's showing
the tweet to be like should i tweet this
you know and they're like i don't know
i'm not a writer but i'm not sure you
should say that first line there he's
like up sent like this guy doesn't care
about anyone he only cares about himself
and he and josh hawley and ted cruz and
all these other people are incredibly
weak and when they have to actually you
know stand up for what they believe in
and they're proven to be cowards and
traitors and everything and liars they
will back down right they're like we'll
never back down they will back down well
we saw that today with steve bannon
right like he was gonna go in he would
well well in the court room hearing he
was supposedly gonna bring war with him
well he said he said and i quote i'm
gonna it's gonna go midi
medieval now i don't know if he has a
hard time saying medieval or
understanding the definition but i can
tell you for a fact that if you don't
bring evidence or other witnesses or uh
gonna go up on the stand to actually you
know address the jurors
it doesn't seem like you're going
medieval that seems like you're cowering
and it seems like that's your go-to play
when you're up against something that is
pressuring you you just give up
well that's what they do
definitely definitely he doesn't
understand what medieval is because what
he did today was not medieval he didn't
do anything i mean he looks like he has
the hygiene of someone from the medieval
times that it could be true it looks
like he's got the plug on his face right
he is decomposing before he goes to jail
the craziest part is this chaos machine
right because he goes in the courtroom
and steve bannon knows because his
lawyer's looking at him and go if you
say anything if you try any tactics or
any [ __ ] in this courtroom when you
are sentenced because you're going to be
found guilty yeah yeah our sentence that
judge is going to use every every
[ __ ] thing that you try to do in
this courtroom against you in your
sentence so steve bannon
heeded the advice of his attorney and
then when he went outside he got in
front of the microphone he's like blah
blah blah blah blah benny thompson has
coveted like doesn't want to address
right
i'm a nazi i'm a nazi i'm a nazi and i'm
a nazi and then you've got the guy who's
blowing the whistle which you know again
like how effective is a piece of plastic
that probably cost 25 cents it worked on
marjory taylor green it worked on matt
gates it worked on steve bannon it will
work against fascists well you know we
actually watched that video on our show
today so i'm going to do another
shameless plug here go over to our
channel we only michael's podcast on
youtube and we we reviewed that video we
reviewed that video today how your dogs
are is that is the dog at the white
house there with you is the dog at the
white house there with you yeah yeah
that is the dog
yeah well uh
let me do another shameless plug while
the dog's still barking
while you're subscribing to
youtube channels go ahead and subscribe
to the midas
touch network
also also i if i would be derelict in my
duty that's what the the
the overall theme was tonight of the
hearing for trump i would be derelict in
my duty if i didn't bring up uh jordy's
pennies here the unapologetically po pro
democracy enamel pins
those are going quick huh union made in
the usa baby
and there you get 10 off these great
pins and everything else in the in the
uh the merch store if you go to
store.minustouch.com use the promo code
justice at
store.midastouch.com use the promo code
justice for ten percent off i don't know
if jordy's still awake he might be
asleep you know he might be asleep he is
he had his wine earlier yeah no i i
don't know i don't know yeah well we do
appreciate all the minus mighty joining
us here on the mind as touch network i
will i will give one more plug yeah okay
because on fridays we have a special
edition of our show which is called
bonehead of the week bonehead of the
week we support democracy you can go
vote on our channel on youtube at the
tonymichaelspod you can vote on twitter
as well and on friday in the second hour
from 10 to 11 we go over who the
bonehead of the week is and this week
it's a family affair who did you put on
bone end of the week we got donald trump
we got ivanka trump we got donald trump
jr oh my god all three of them are in
the running right now i'm pretty sure
which one i know which one's gonna win
yeah we've also got other people that we
present after the whoever the winner and
the contestants are during the show but
for those who are still watching
i don't think you're going to want to
miss it it's going to be good there's
tons of material and we clearly saw a
good portion of it during the hearing
tonight so go to our twitter account at
tonymichaelspod you can vote there or go
to the youtube channel the tony michaels
podcast here on youtube you can vote for
bonehead of the week you decide
you get to vote who the bone of the week
is and we break it down on fridays
because gabe we broadcast every single
weekday for two full hours monday
through friday noon eastern 11 central
nine pacific on youtube twitter and
twitch and we simulcast from the midas
touch facebook page but we're going to
come back for more of these hearings so
don't forget to subscribe to the mind as
touch network
gabe
i i normally say surf's up but
have a good great night thanks for
joining us thanks for being here with us
don't miss everyone who is here and who
who stuck around the 5 400 and so people
yeah yeah they're saying we are
incredibly grateful for the people that
have that have stayed through
and that learned some new things some
embarrassing things about trump but some
new things
and uh we i mean we wouldn't be here if
it weren't for the people that were
watching and so i just want to say thank
you for the people that are supporting
independent journalism like we said so
many times on the show we wouldn't be
here if it weren't for you all
so thank you and good night
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
meal born head ass speaking